Experience.
Larry.
Rob Bar,
ladies,
gentlemen.
What's up dude?
Nothing that feeling good.
California weed.
Gotcha.
Right?
A little bit.
It's not the same.
No,
no.
There is no weed and Queens.
Queens is,
you've got to go to the Bronx.
I used to go to up to four of them to get weed Queens,
isn't it?
Where are you from?
Well,
I used to,
I was born in New Jersey.
I lived in Boston for most of my young adult life when I lived in New York and
lived in new Rochelle,
which is,
yeah,
which is sad,
but that's like close to where weed is.
Yeah.
But I never,
I didn't smoke weed back then.
Very,
very rarely.
I didn't really smoke weed until I was 30 living here.
Right.
So I discovered weed and I was just like,
man,
movies who knew ice cream?
It's delicious.
That movies were amazing.
Everything is better.
So that was like,
oh my God,
there's like Ben folds is great.
Soon as you take your first hit of weed,
you're just like,
oh my God,
Ben folds.
And those are the things that people don't like about people that smoke weed.
When they talk about it like a,
Oh my God,
it's moves amazing.
Oh look at this sunset shot eight is the sunsets.
Incredible.
It's a weird,
that's a weird thing with the,
the people that don't like the effects of pock cause he affects a pot.
It's just like you become calmer and like super appreciative of everything.
Like you know,
they'll call it like stone or talk,
but what it really is like recognizing the wondering things that you ordinarily
take for granted.
You know,
I think a lot of that has to do at time dilation because things feel longer.
So I think you're able to appreciate things in the moment a little bit more.
Yeah.
But definitely possible.
That's like a minute.
It feels like two minutes.
Yeah.
I think there's a bunch of things going on,
right?
No,
that's it.
That's the only thing.
Why does life seem shorter though?
It seems like every year it goes faster.
Is that because we're so stoned and it's like it doesn't add up?
No,
I think that's just a facet of recognizing how brief it really is.
As you get older and you hit 40 you go,
oh Jesus.
If everything goes great,
I'm at the halfway point.
Like if I don't get cancer,
hit by a bus,
dying,
I was car accident,
like all these different variables that you start to consider and then you
realize like how when you work all day too,
you think about how quick God Damn Day goes by and you're saying that things
slow down when you get older.
Now I'm saying you're saying it,
it slows down when you smoke weed,
you know and appreciate everything,
but yet life seems like it's going faster at the same time,
but as I've gotten older,
I've actually been way more appreciative of things.
I don't know,
like in my twenties I was just like,
who cares?
Yeah,
no,
I'm way more appreciative too.
But I agree with you that time does seem like it's going fast.
Oh my God.
Yeah,
it's February.
Isn't that amazing?
It was just January.
Yeah.
Well not only that,
it was just July.
It was hot.
It's like a year is not nearly as long as we used to think it was.
And I think part of that also is when you were a kid,
you were in fucking school and those nine months of classes seemed like forever.
It's an eternity because you're forced to do something you don't want to do.
Once you get older and you know you,
you kind of recognize what that really was.
You realize how short a year actually is,
but if you ask a 21 year old right now,
it's like,
is Liz as a year long?
And they're like,
did,
it's totally long.
Like I wonder if they,
if they feel it's a good impression of a 21 year old,
well,
it's a percentage of their life to
20 years old and you know,
you'll see,
you see things in a different perspective when you're older.
Yeah.
You know,
you could look back on two years and it's just like,
oh my God.
Like that two years was nothing.
When you're a kid,
you're just like,
that's like a third of my life.
Two years.
We're time travelers.
Yeah.
I mean,
when you're a little kid,
like every year is a huge deal,
you know?
That's why you say like,
I'm four and a half,
you know?
No one says I'm 24 and a half match.
If you're dating a girl and you go,
how old are you?
And she's like 24 and a half.
I feel like I got to go.
You're fucking,
you're six.
You're like,
you have some genetic abnormality.
It makes you look like you're 24,
24 and a forth.
Yeah.
There's,
that's a weird thing about kids today,
right?
With this,
um,
this thing that they're saying that the hormones in the meat or causing them to
reach puberty quicker than ever before,
and that girls that are like 12 and 13 years old,
they look like women and they're getting for,
have you noticed girls are getting furrier lately?
I think it's from the knees.
This your own subs.
So wait,
hold on your own test.
You notice that?
No,
not,
there's hormones in meat that are making kids grow up quicker.
They,
there's a bunch of factors that they believe are making kids grow quicker and
reach puberty quicker and also become larger.
They think it's a high protein diet that Americans take.
Like we,
we have incredibly abundant resources when it comes to food and crazy and meat
protein,
all hormone filled and,
and on top of that antibiotics are thinking of antibiotics or having a weird
effect on people because you're absorbing a certain amount of it from the food
that you eat.
Right.
There's a lot of variables.
So why or when you look back at humans from like a hundred years ago,
why are they so much smaller?
They didn't have much food.
Is that it?
Yeah,
it was hard to get food.
I don't even mean fat.
Smaller,
like just smaller,
small.
That's a vulnerable.
Having not having enough food.
Right.
You know,
you,
when you look at what people can do today,
we just go into a supermarket,
you get cold meat.
Like that wasn't,
that wasn't that easy.
Right?
Right.
There was no freezers.
I just saw a documentary about the Russian hockey team and they were saying how
they came to America for the first time in the 70s like the one that we beat in
the 80 [inaudible] and they were like,
you can get vegetables in the winter.
What does this mean?
Yeah,
right.
How do you get fruit and vegetables when people can't grow them here?
Yeah.
Our shipping,
the ability to get oranges from Florida to New Mexico,
it's fucking incredible.
Like that's never existed in time.
So a hundred years ago they had to eat what was near them and they had the ice
house.
Where I'm at tonight in Pasadena was an ice house.
It was a place they would take giant blocks of ice from the great north.
They would put them on boats,
they would put them in these cargoes that were insulated.
They're these thick walls and steel and all this different stuff to try to
encapsulate the cold.
And then they would bring them to a,
and you would go and buy ice and you'd put it in your ice box.
So if you had milk or something like that.
And he didn't want it to go bad.
You want it to last like two days,
no preservatives.
There's just no preserved.
Right.
They didn't have any,
you had to just store everything,
everything,
but not only that,
everything went quick.
You couldn't,
you had to keep shopping.
You had to go to the grocery store like every other day.
And when are we talking?
When is a hundred years ago?
Hundred years ago.
Yeah.
So the people that you're looking at these little tiny like civil war people,
men were like 125 pounds.
That was like the average size for a man.
A briefly.
It's like,
yeah,
I mean,
you know,
everybody's always comparing.
Like what if the current athletes played athletes from the 60s it would destroy,
that would be such a slaughter fest.
People are bigger,
faster,
and not even without steroids.
It would be a few people that would,
it's always,
yeah,
it's crazy when people are just like,
well,
what if will Chamberlain went against Lebron James and it's like not even a
contest,
but if we'll,
we'll Chaim was still a giant man.
The other thing is if will Chamberlain live today speed.
They didn't have the,
the game is so great,
quicker and different in every sport,
but don't you think that they like will Chamberlain was a super athlete.
He was a big,
tall,
strong dude.
So if he just got involved in the same sort of strength and conditioning
programs that today's modern athletes get involved with,
understood nutrition,
recovery,
all the different shit that like Koby Bryant does.
Like Coby Brian was one of the first guys to go to Germany and get that blood
spinning procedure and I know he's on,
he was on top of the cryogenic thing too before anybody goes to those 250 degree
below zero booths for like three weeks.
Why is that legal of steroids aren't?
Well,
it's not as good.
That's why it's,
it's pretty good,
but it's not.
It's just steroids.
Steroids turned you into a super person,
right?
But what these guys can do today with all that is partially why they're so good.
And also that people imitate their atmosphere.
If you're around a bunch of Michael Jordan Hansen elevates the game.
It's not that the physical capabilities of the elite athletes are that much
different.
I think you just,
you have to be better.
Yeah.
You look at your,
the people who came before you and you're not going to be like,
well I'll settle for half of what they did.
You're going to be like,
I gotta be better than that.
Could you imagine if like Babe Ruth came back and tried to compete against Jose
Conseco when Jose can,
Seiko was in his juice in prime,
first of all,
I feel like Babe Ruth would be brought up on rape charges
or just be like,
he would be the bill Cosby baseball.
Like that was probably just like,
oh yeah,
of course.
She said no,
what,
you're on the Yankees.
Yeah.
Well I think rape was probably like super duper duper common.
You know,
a thousand years ago were like almost everybody raped.
I guarantee you can go back to a point of like really primitive man what?
It was unbelievably common.
And I think that's like one of the things that people are freaking out about
today.
Like when you know this whole argument about rape culture and discussion about
rape jokes and all those things are like in a court,
like how funny of a defense that would be.
It like go back a hundred years ago,
man.
So I have a slave
dude.
Do you not know how this country was founded?
And it looks like the Second Amendment argument,
you know this country's founded to right to bear arms,
salsa founded by people that owned slaves.
Like those people you worship were slave owners.
Yeah.
And it was founded by people who couldn't fit in in Europe.
People who just were like,
I don't write,
you know,
I'm,
I'm the Weirdo here.
And people that were so fucking fed up that they got in a boat with no
vegetables and they went across the ocean.
No vegetables,
no energy bars.
A lot of them got sick as fuck.
People died on that trip.
I mean that's a long trip.
Was Shitty,
shitty food.
And what did they eat back then?
Like beef jerky and stuff.
Like what could they preserve fish?
I'd probably just say fifth.
They caught they did they catch fish?
Is that,
is that proven?
They would have to try to catch fish.
Why would you not?
You're in the ocean.
Yeah,
that'd be crazy.
I would assume grain.
Probably a lot of grain.
Well they're also always traveling to like when you're fishing,
like presumably the law,
even if you're trolling,
which means like pulling over behind.
I would imagine the boat would be going faster than that.
If it's got oars,
I mean,
and uh,
sales rather than those big crazy fucking sales.
I bet they're going faster than you would want to troll for.
So you're not going to slow down on the off chance that you catch a fish.
What's trolling?
Trolling is like when they take a line and they pull up behind a boat with a
hook and a,
a flashy lure and the fish see it and they think that's a fish transform away
and they chase after it and they eat it.
They almost instinctive.
They can't help themselves,
but it's really great.
Yeah,
it's a boring way to fishing.
I just went deep sea fishing in Redondo beach this weekend.
We just dropped a line down and I had a really bad experience.
I caught a Pelican alive pelican cause I didn't drop it quick enough and the
Pelicans,
we'll go for it.
I caught like,
I think a 50 pound Pelican,
like this Pelican was gigantic and they had to like some do.
Some captain dude came out.
He's like,
I got this.
And he pulled the Pelichet out by his beak out of the water and had to like cut
the hookup.
So he's just like living with a hook and I'm done.
Anyway,
thing happened once with a seal,
a seal,
a store,
a seal or sea lion.
One of those fucking things I was fishing with these guys is camera dudes from
news radio where like there were big time fisherman.
They'd go out every weekend though again.
The show must be so fun.
Yeah.
And I'm like,
all right,
one day I was like,
come on,
let's go,
let's go.
So we all went out for shit.
I fucking didn't get any visual.
I caught a fucking seal.
Did you?
Did you take it?
No,
we had to cut the line.
It was so awful.
Like it's a mammal.
It's got a hook in its mouth.
It personality.
It's a testament to the intelligence of dolphins because you never hear about
someone accidentally catch a dolphin.
You mean they,
that's what they used to eat back in the day though.
They would just get one big dolphin and feed 20 people and then they might have
eight dolphins are bigger fish instead of trying to catch these people
definitely killed dolphins,
but they would never,
they're not seeing the cove.
That's why,
I mean they kill and eat dolphins for sure.
They always have been,
but they don't catch them with hooks.
I mean if you,
you'd have to like,
you'd have to Jig them,
which means like you'd have to pass,
throw the hook over their body and pull on it.
Like catch their body.
They're not going to willingly bite a fake fish.
They're too smart now,
but dolphins are so nice.
They probably came up with like,
Hey,
can we help you guys?
And they're just like,
there's definitely been some of that,
hey,
what's up guys?
You need help.
If they probably ate cuter things back in the day,
like that.
Things that usually you'll be like,
oh look a seal or like have a little baby sea lion and you know that back then
that was like,
no,
that's like Turkey dinner for like three weeks for our village or something.
Yeah.
I think we think things are too cute,
man.
You gotta get over how cute things are.
Is that the first bird that you almost killed?
You killed a bird before.
Never killed.
I've never killed a bird.
Um,
even killing a fish is weird,
you know,
I'm not from the country where I've,
I grew up killing anything.
Killing things are weird.
I Dunno.
It's weird.
Killing bugs sometimes.
Yeah.
It's weird thing to feel weird.
It's like weird to take a life,
but you know,
you got it.
I got to eat here,
but it's even weirder that we have somebody else do it.
Oh,
supermarket cool with that.
That's,
that's the weirdest part about it though,
isn't it?
It is and it's cool.
It's cool.
It's cool to be able to get like to just be able to go to the store and they
have lamb,
you know,
fucking amount of effort you would have to go through to get a sheep and kill it
and butcher it and raise it pieces and then kill it.
Fuck,
you got to be friends with it for awhile.
So these people who are doing it are doing us a huge service,
but there's also a weirdness with people if you don't like,
you don't think of yourself as being a killer while you're wearing like leather
shoes you got belt on.
It's made out of Nike.
That's made by like Filipino kids with bloody fingers,
no fingernails.
China of course we can't,
we can't think about this stuff dehydrated.
That's like the contract we make when we're like we want to live in a society
where we have convenience,
right?
Yeah.
I was listening to this radio lab podcast about cities and they were talking
about like the hectic crazy pace of cities and they were saying that the pace is
directly
mathematically related to how many people live in the city.
The pace,
the pace.
The pace of the way you talk,
the amount of syllables per second,
the amount of steps per minute that you take when you're walking directly
related to the population of the city.
It was amazing.
They're like broke it down as a matter of mathematical equation with these like
physicists that they thought this through and they've done all these tests where
they called people,
they called post offices,
they called in,
they,
they set up like a weigh points like here's like the start,
here's the beginning.
And they measured everybody who walks through that way point like an unknown way
point.
They had no idea there are being studied.
They put a piece of string down on the ground,
they tied it to one post and another pro.
So they have an arbitrary beginning start time and end time.
And these people would walk through it and they would count in every city what
is the average number?
So this guy walked 20 feet per second or whatever.
This guy walked 15 and they would figure out how many steps and they would throw
it all into a computer and they found out that it's directly proportional to how
many people live in the area.
It is the fastest walkers.
Do you remember?
Well I didn't pay attention.
I was just fascinated.
They were just ringing and they would just read out a bunch of numbers.
Should be skinny though,
you know cause well la be one of the most per capita people that live in the
city and the most people in the purse city.
Right.
What do you imagine?
I didn't say,
well there's a lot of people in la but la is also spread out.
But you shouldn't be skinny because what you fucking eat and drink like that's
so dumb that you think that way.
I walked so much.
But if you walk a mile a day,
yeah,
probably sprain your ankle.
I just don't think I'm a fast walker.
But
you have to walk a lot I think to actually like lose weight from it.
Yeah.
I would assume sometimes I got into biking at some point and I was like,
here we go.
This is,
here comes the exercise.
Do you know a little exercise?
Biking is used to ride like 25 miles a day to get like a really good workout and
that's a lot of risk.
25 miles is 25 miles of lottery,
25 million lines of possibility where cars can hit you.
Lions,
cars,
cars.
I'm talking about real things.
Cars.
Yeah.
Mountain lions are a problem with people with dirt bike ride.
Really?
Yeah.
They say it's like a rolling a ball of yarn passed a cat.
You know a cat can't resist themselves when they see a mountain back go by,
they think is trying to run from them.
I hear they're fine with people though.
Like hikers and stuff.
Is that true?
No,
no,
no.
Mountain lions in Griffith and like I go hiking there.
Am I at risk?
Oh,
for sure.
Yeah.
I mean most likely the mountain lions going to stay clear of you because they've
learned over the years that when you fuck with people usually get killed.
So they develop these instincts to stay shy of people,
but if the wrong mountain line with a sprained ankle finds you,
your,
you know,
you're there when it's hungry and it says,
fuck it,
I'm not starving to death and it just takes you down,
that can happen to it there.
It doesn't happen that often.
Jury's kind of out on how you deal with the
mountain lion attack.
Right.
It's not the same as a bear.
You don't play dead,
right?
No,
no,
no.
You fight back,
fight back.
You Punch it in the fight back.
Is that a shark?
Well,
you do whatever you can.
If you can punch,
do whatever you can.
You want to make it so that it's worried about being injured by yes.
Big l l yeah.
It's supposed to like jump your arms up in the air,
but you're all oddly enough,
you're not supposed to make eye contact with it.
It sounds like my sex life.
Terrible.
Joe.
Sorry again,
your shirt.
Take off your shirt,
make it into a ball and throw it.
I pretend to be really big.
I threw my shirt and I would do cat things.
I think it's cause it's still can't work.
Do that with a cat.
It's going
let you roll a ball past him.
Talk about the large cats are so terrifying to me.
Mountain lions are awful.
If you get bitten by one,
they're awful.
It's just gotten bitten by one.
A Guy I got to see that you coupon mountain line at some point too that I could
see a guy in Cupertino.
Uh,
his kid,
his six year old kid got attacked right in front of them.
They were walking on a trail.
That's where apple is.
Mount line jumps out.
Bites a kid.
There's mountain lions like in Hollywood.
Yeah,
I saw it.
I saw a fox on the street in Hollywood.
Fox just walking around.
Oh yeah.
In Los Feliz and shit.
What wasn't a cougar?
Uh,
I don't know what her real fox.
Yeah.
Real Fox.
They have real foxes in La.
We made like a fake Fox.
He was trying to say like foxy lady.
No,
no.
Oh yeah.
Foxy lady
was a fuck.
Hey,
sell this real facts in Lowe's.
Feel it.
Know I didn't think that boxes,
we're not like a Fox walking around.
My friend's cat just got eaten by coyotes.
That happens all the time.
Yeah.
Wow.
Did you see there was a article showing frozen people and animals and people
that have died from being frozen like it's a little,
there's a lot of homeless people just like sitting there and I would like a park
bench frozen,
but one thing was interesting was a Jamie.
They have a,
like if you see Fox frozen in water,
it's a Fox that was trying to cross this water and it just froze like mid,
mid thing it,
there's an elk that was frozen standing up and then coyotes ate it while it was
standing up.
Yeah.
So it's like just skeleton standing up in a field stuck in the snow and ice.
It's so creepy to homeless people in the,
there was one guy with like his eyes wide open looking.
Oh yeah,
look at that.
This bottom one,
right?
That,
why is it PSI so messed up?
Because it's frozen.
Super cold.
A little bit better I think.
But I'm actually,
you know what?
I'm cool with animals that died naturally in the wild.
They all died naturally.
I mean,
everything is,
you know,
it'd be unnatural if they stayed alive.
Unless this has to do with global warming.
I'm fine with it.
Can we prove that this has nothing to do with global warming?
And what did,
what are your thoughts on global warming?
Love it.
Happy,
huge fan.
Uh,
my thoughts on it.
I,
you know what,
um,
I mean it's hard to deny that something fucked up is happening right now,
right?
Yeah.
Pretty hard to deny.
I definitely believe that we've fucked things up.
I don't know if we have,
I think we certainly have done a lot of damage as far as like pollution and
particulates.
But I listened to people that say that they know that we have done it and I
believed them and I trust them.
I mean,
scientists.
Yeah.
But I don't know,
you know,
I have no,
I'm an idiot.
I don't,
we believe scientists on that.
Well,
I certainly do.
I mean,
I,
what I'm saying is I don't know what the fuck is going on.
I'm listening to them.
And they're making a lot of sense and I would always go towards the scientists,
but I have no idea.
Like whether or not people were actually causing global warming or whether or
not global warming is going to be the sky is falling moment.
That 2000 wasn't for the 2012 wasn't,
I don't know,
just feel like it's,
it's so scary that we are just like,
I don't want to deal with that right now.
I think so,
yeah.
I think it's like one of these things where in order to actually deal with it,
we'd have to be way more scared right now because every time a report comes out,
scientists are just like,
yeah it's going to be all over and like 20 years,
you know?
But didn't they say that about aids to that aids would be over.
We'd all be dead by [inaudible] 97 or something like that.
Did they say fuck yeah they were,
there were some doom and gloom motherfuckers back when when Magic Johnson came
out with aids.
That's when everybody fucking panic cause it was like a Zombie movie where the
president goes on TV and tells you he's a Zombie.
I'm sorry I'm going to become a Zombie and a couple of days like what?
Like Magic Johnson Johnson was the king.
He says
fucking huge super athletes and just one of the best basketball players of all
time.
It would be like if Lebron came out with global warming,
like he just was like I have global.
Oh my God the prawns got global warming.
Is there any positive things about aids though?
Just like let it like besides weight loss and stuff like that,
is there anything positive to look at it because like I know so many people that
have aids now and they're,
they're like they don't have aids.
HIV positive.
You probably get to do a lot of interviews.
I don't know.
Well I've seen this.
There was some scientific study they did where they injected a sick person with
HIV,
like the HIV to combat some other disease.
Like it was an inner form of HIV.
I didn't hear you hear about that.
Didn't we cure it?
Well,
this is what they're trying to do now.
They're trying to,
this is like some radical new form of therapy for certain diseases.
I can cancer even they're injecting like diseases into the disease.
So the disease fights the cancer or the other way around.
I think cancer can defeat aids.
It's like Freddy versus Jason.
It's like rock,
paper,
scissors of diseases.
You would never think the paper would be to ride,
but it does.
That's true.
I'm not even kidding.
I think that there's something like if you inject a certain type of cancer into
an aid sale,
it just goes like,
it just fucking kills the aids.
Well,
there's no aids sell,
right?
There's t cells that are bad and it's your immune system that's shot.
So with with aids it'll be really hard I think.
I think,
yeah,
it's not,
there's like an actual,
like you could see what aids looks like.
There's like a photo of AIDS when you want to bring something up on Google photo
of AIDS.
This is a photo of the virus,
right?
Yeah.
Can they find that isolated in your body?
I know that they did.
The HIV thing with a tumor because they could find the tumor and then just shoot
something into it.
So you could possibly put HIV and herpes and have HIV instead of herpes.
And some people have actually probably rather have that would want that.
I don't know.
Herpes is,
well,
how are those drugs,
those protease inhibitors,
those are,
are those really bad for your body?
For Eight,
the HIV?
Oh yeah.
I mean,
I don't think that they're as bad anymore.
I hear AIDS belly is a thing now you get like aids belly.
I'm not kidding.
Like there's like you can stand up.
This is very,
it's belly.
No,
no,
there's,
there were all these ads all over New York at some point that we're like,
are you dealing with AIDS belly?
She get the fuck out of there.
Where to God,
there's a thing.
Call in if you guys have aids,
might be one of those things that someone created as a marketing ploy.
I'm trying to sell my average for men and it's not worried or aid the AIDS
belly.
Do you suffer from AIDS belly?
Um,
I thought that was a real commercial for a second.
Uh,
yeah,
I,
I hear that you just,
I think it's the pills that distend your belly.
Um,
I don't know.
We know a dude who has HIV.
He's fine.
Yeah,
Eddie too.
I've known several people that got it and I was looking at the same,
gosh longer.
I don't know.
Maybe we'll talk later.
Yeah.
Don't want to out somebody but magic Johnson.
No,
no,
no.
I can actual person I actually know and you know,
he's,
he's fine.
I just told him I understand how we thought that it was going to kill everybody.
Well,
I guess I understand scientists to figure it out a way to cure most of the
issues that come along with that disease.
So what was a death sentence?
Well,
you're all,
I'm assuming,
I don't know this person,
you know,
but I'm assuming that they are of the middle class and they are like,
they're not like a poor poverty stricken person.
Right.
He's not wealthy by any stretch of the imagination.
No,
no.
It think it's all,
it's,
he's actually probably pretty poor.
It's all paid for by insurance insurance,
which is,
I assume people still do die of AIDS,
right?
That's it.
That's the question we were asking actually asking this the other night.
We're like wounds.
The last time you heard about someone dying of aids,
like it used to be you'd Freddie Mercury died of aids.
Holy Shit,
Freddie Margarie fuck.
Like there was always these people that were dying of aids.
You don't hear that anymore,
you know?
Right.
Definitely not high profile people.
I haven't really even know about low profile.
Okay.
Eight let's just,
we don't know.
So let's just take a guess.
AIDS deaths per year would 2014 let's say 2014 do you think might be adding like
2009 in it?
I would say seventy thousand sixty thousand this is like a really dark prices,
right?
I realize that many.
Yeah,
I still 60,000
I would say even maybe even in the u s let's say the u s because here's where it
gets funky when they start counting Africa and one of the reason why it gets
funky is because if you say HIV USA,
USA,
let's just go with USA.
Okay.
Because if you go with the world,
the real problem with the world is as explained,
explained to me in Africa,
it's easy.
They can get funding from AIDS organizations.
If someone has HIV,
they,
the lawyer will say,
you know,
this person is getting aids.
They're,
they're testing positive for aids and this is like,
there's x amount of AIDS cases,
but they might not have HIV and they're not going to test him for it.
What?
They might have a bunch of different diseases,
like an Africa,
you could have a whole host of different diseases that destroy your immune
system,
so they might have HIV,
but they also might have a bunch of other shit.
That's what I was going to say,
like you die of pneumonia,
right?
When they say 30,000 when they say those numbers in Africa,
what it's been explained to me by legit scientists is that it's possible that
you have to consider that those people don't all have HIV.
It might be unrelated illnesses that's causing their immune system to get
destroyed.
Some of them might have HIV,
HIV,
but some of them might have cancers and toxic poisoning.
Who knows?
There could be a lot of other issues,
so they don't,
yeah,
they just seeing people who have aids,
they're not testing every single person that they throw into this grand number,
but that's not in the u s in the u s so in the u s yeah,
that's what I was saying.
Let's go with the s not worldwide.
What do you want to say?
I'm going to,
I'm going to say a 20,000 okay.
I say 12 I say 60 I say one the US died of AIDS in 2014
here we go.
An estimated 1.5 million people die for 2013 39 million people have died
worldwide.
We're so dumb.
What's wrong with us?
An estimated one point feel so dumb.
Right.
And people,
this is worldwide.
A worldwide.
Okay.
Africa is 90% still 1.4 that Christ subsaharan Africa.
Here it is.
Subsaharan Africa has the biggest burden of HIV AIDS with almost 70% of the
global total of new HIV infections.
But that's HIV.
Hmm.
That's not good enough.
Saying AIDS.
You've got to say in theU s aids related deaths in the US in 2010 HIV was a
seventh leading cause of death.
Huh.
That sounds like a lot of people.
1.1 million people in the u s right now are living with HIV dad.
Oh,
here we go.
I was right.
The estimated deaths 13,834 with a you were closest.
Yeah,
and that was in 2011
okay.
So I,
you know,
that sounds like a lot.
That's a lot of people.
I mean that's a lot of people.
Still a lot of people.
If it's the seventh yeah.
If I look at something like pneumonia or even chicken pox or how many people die
year,
how
many people die of alcohol?
Oh,
things like that one.
Oh that's giant.
That's seventy thousand seventy thousand plus in America every year.
Every year.
Just directly from drinking themselves to death.
Yeah,
but that's not even like car related deaths from alcohol.
That's not domestic violence.
Murder.
How many from pot?
Zero.
Yeah,
zero.
There's probably been some people that have done some stupid shit that's caused
them to die because they were on pot dabs.
If you smoked pot and then just drove off the fucking bridge cause you spaced
and you drowned,
there's pot take that hit who who gets,
I mean essentially are their numbers.
I don't think there must be.
There must be.
I mean,
I don't know if you've heard that and all these anti legalization arguments I've
ever heard those numbers.
Well it's probably not nearly as prevalent because it doesn't affect your motor
skills the way alcohol does.
Like everybody knows across the board that if you drink,
you get drunk,
you're compromised.
But Pot doesn't really compromise your physically.
So did numbers are going to be way different alcohols like 100% like you pull
people over and they're drunk,
they're not driving as good.
It's 100% if you've had seven drinks and you get in the car,
you just don't drive as good as you do when you're sober.
It's 100% but there's people that can get high as fuck and get in a car and
drive.
Excellent.
And there's no issue that's driving really poorly,
really high.
They've actually done studies.
I've test some people,
no recognizable issues except when they get to high,
it's by,
but these people are probably rookies.
They're getting these rookies that don't get high and they're getting them too
high and they fucking,
they're turning corners and they panic and the mid corner,
you know what happens when I get really manic drive?
I forget.
I'm driving for a few minutes.
Yeah,
like you're driving and you're just like your,
your mind is wandering to something else.
You've got the Ben Folds Alabama.
But yeah,
that's true.
That's scary too because you're always thinking like,
what was I doing for like the last 10 minutes was I even like awake at this
time?
It's too loud.
My headphones went out.
Oh,
went out.
You know that weird thing,
that weird thing that people do where you are in the middle of doing something
and you go,
Whoa,
how the fuck did I get here?
Like how did I,
how did I zone out and autopilot all the way home,
took all the turns and then you're driving.
You mean drop street?
No,
totally sober.
Just space out,
but do everything correctly.
I've done,
oh,
I do that.
I forget why.
I went into a certain room of my apartment a lot.
Like I'll just be like,
I got to go to the kitchen and I'll be in the kitchen.
I'm like,
what did I need in the kitchen?
I remember walking in there,
I guess.
Yeah.
Sometimes when I'm driving I went like miles and I'm like,
oh,
I'm already past this spot.
Yeah.
And it sucks because when you come out of realizing that you're like,
am I still in it?
Am I still in my driving like,
like you're still kind of trying to catch up to the now cause you're thinking so
much like trying to figure out what you were doing in the past that you're not
even paying attention to what you're doing.
Yeah.
No,
I mean I do in the shower all the time.
I'll just shower everything and forget that I've watched anything.
Oh yeah.
I'll be like,
did I wash any part of my body?
And then all of a sudden they'll be like,
oh I guess and then I'll just shower again.
Or you forgot that you forgot to wash the butthole and then you have to turn the
shower back on it.
I don't smoke pot.
Have these problems everybody does.
Everybody has one of the things they say to cured Alzheimer's or to prevent it
as much as possible.
You're supposed to take different routes to work.
He's supposed to drive different ways to prevent Alzheimer's.
Yeah.
Not to prevent it,
but to slow down the onset if it's coming.
If you have it,
they say,
they say that when people go and do the same thing every day and the exact same
order,
there's no unusual input.
So your brain just recognizes it.
Site as a on a subconscious level and never has to process like I don't have to
process,
I get this.
So it becomes atrophied.
Yeah.
I feel that I feel creatively atrophied when I don't meet new people or don't
see a new place.
If you're just seeing the same people every day,
you just feel like,
like your mind is dying.
Well yeah,
you get bored.
Just get blocked into the same experience over and over and over again.
Yeah.
Driving around like going,
I think probably move into a new fucking place.
It'd be really smart for us to,
I mean that's what we all were designed for.
We're designed,
we're hunter gatherers.
That's what we're,
that's our DNA.
I just like,
I think about too,
and you know I,
you tour all the time and I,
I travel on the road to do stand up and it's like,
I wonder what that does to my mind to have to get used to a city for four days
and be alone.
Like that's a weird thing on things.
Weird.
It's so weird.
I go so many days where I don't talk to anyone and the first time I talked to
people is an hour of stand up.
Yeah.
Like that's like crazy.
What does that do to your brain?
It's not good.
It can't be right.
A lot of comics get depressed when they do the road.
Oh yeah.
I figured out a way to stop that early.
What do you do?
Bring your friends.
I want to bring friends on the road with me.
I really,
and my toy where you could get openers,
don't let me bring open,
I did it back then.
That's the only way I did it.
I demanded it.
Yeah.
I've been doing it that way since the 90 [inaudible] it is so much more fun when
they let me do that.
I just tell them,
I go,
look,
I'm,
I'm going to bring you a great comic.
I'm going to give you a great show.
I'll pay for his airfare.
I'll,
I took the heads financially to bring guys out cause it was like,
it's way better.
There's a difference between making 500 extra bucks and being miserable and
lonely or even 500 less bucks and hanging out with your friend.
And it's good for them too because it gives these guys who might be landlocked
in La.
I take them on the road,
expose them to these clubs and then chill and then like,
like Hinchcliffe I just,
I took him to the comedy works in Denver and then he got booked as a headliner
after you opened for me.
So it was like,
you know,
you can,
you can do that and you can get guys in the door that way too,
you know?
Yeah.
It's great.
I love to bring people,
I mean it's got it.
Force your agent into doing it for you and just tell them this is the show.
It just keeps you from just needing to masturbate all day.
Like I just all day,
man,
that's where you're wrong is crazy.
Doesn't keep you from doing that.
Oh,
you gotta do it anyway.
[inaudible] I forgot
something back in my room.
Guys knocking on your door.
10 minutes later.
Are we still going to have lunch?
Hey,
I'm,
oh,
I'm still,
I can't find it.
I went back to the flashlight the other day and I was like,
why did I leave this?
This?
I had never done it.
I've never done it.
That's good.
Yeah.
We used to have a sponsor.
Oh,
I'd never at one of our earliest,
can I get one?
How do I wish?
Were they expensive round?
We had a box of them.
Do we still have a box from here?
Did I bring a box in?
See if you can find one for me.
That video where they interviewed the girl who's the model for the fleshlight?
Yeah,
the zone model.
They are there.
I don't know that.
Maybe they lied about that,
but they said she's probably shit.
It doesn't live or give a giant in there.
It looks like some sort of a octopus thing.
Romanian this and she's like,
I'm so proud it's my vagina.
That was one of those local news pieces where they go,
this is what we're going to tell you.
We're going to tell you the flesh line.
10th anniversary of being Montenegro.
Yeah,
he's got one.
Well,
that's the good one.
It looks like a beer cans.
They could just keep it in the fridge.
This,
yeah,
that's a mouth one to rub her mouth.
It looks like a can.
I literally had some sponsors or some,
uh,
guests that told me I can't be on an episode where you do that,
will you?
Will you have the,
like Sam Harris,
first time he came on and it was like one of the stipulations.
What he couldn't,
we couldn't have that as a sponsor for the episode that he was on.
Why?
Because he didn't want to be associated with a rubber vagina.
That's so crazy.
And he's a neuroscientist and an author and a respected intellectual.
It's crazy.
Couldn't you just not do it on that episode then?
That's what I did.
You miss them.
I miss them.
What you meant to fleshlight they were so fun to talk about all the time and I
don't miss,
we said what?
As much as we could have.
What would you say is the biggest advantage to using a flashlight?
Doesn't feel like your hand,
it feels like,
I mean if you put the right lotion on it actually feels pretty good.
It's crazy.
I haven't done it in like a long time so I was like,
I was like Oh my God this is but then the,
she's got grossed out a little bit.
You should,
it just grows.
I just felt a little gross.
It's um,
it's just,
they designed some sort of a rubbery,
I don't know what the way I actually use,
it's almost like a food based thing.
I think it was like gelatin based but it feels like human flesh.
It's way better than your hand because your hand,
you feel I know hand signals.
I do have times where I'm like need,
there needs to be more,
you know like I need more out of this.
I don't know what I need to do differently.
That's a commitment though.
Fuck that thing.
Cause you got to wash it afterwards and it's just,
you feel like a loser.
Oh wash it.
You shoot up a load into his fucking rubber tube.
You're like,
what is wrong with me?
I just want to get to the point financially where I could just throw it out.
Just get a new one.
How much do they call?
Well,
they're like,
that's registering.
They're pretty expensive,
but when we were getting them for free,
I used to do that.
I got ready,
like I'll be like,
ah,
I just leave it on the nightstand and then two days later I'm like,
you know what?
I'm just throwing this away.
Yeah,
you don't want to wash four day old come out of your flesh and my girlfriend do
it.
I'll just hire a housekeeper.
No,
no,
no.
You don't have to vacuum clean these things is a box of them.
There's like a hamper full by the bed.
There's a great video in like,
I think it's like local news in China where they see one of these and like a
puddle of water and they think it's a new fish that they've discovered a species
of fish.
That was hilarious.
I don't believe that.
I think
he says it.
It's true.
No,
it was on the news was on the news.
That's how I found out it.
It
has to be true,
but when you see it though,
it looks like a fish.
There's no way there's the photo of HIV.
Whoa.
It looks like we aim on backup.
Does.
Did you pull it up?
I asked him to,
yeah.
Yeah.
I didn't see that.
It wasn't looking.
That's what HIV looks like.
Did you show us this,
Jeremy?
Yeah.
They took one on the bottom left.
It looks like.
Oh my God.
It looks exactly like we'd aids is weed.
They convinced the other cells to attach it.
It's just weird,
man.
It looks like the Geo Dome that Pauly Shore Stephen Baldwin wearing,
but it's covered by we'd donuts.
Wow.
It's covered by the phone lights.
Remember biodome
areas,
but it's green.
Oh my God.
Look at the one up top.
Look at the one above that.
Jamie.
Go up there.
That that one is the blue strings.
What the fuck?
Why is that one so different looking smoke.
What said that in the article it said HIV is evolving.
What does it say?
Jammy.
That's crazy.
Click on it.
Again.
Evolving to be less deadly.
Whoa.
That's fascinating because it likes us started being rude,
just trying to kill him.
[inaudible] PC.
The will.
I realize this is just less flair in the world when all those gay people start
dropping like flies.
What?
To be honest,
the guy that wrote this article and he has one nice,
so maybe read something wrong and he's a contributor.
He's not a writer,
he's not a writer.
Well,
let's see the image.
Look at the image of that thing.
It's crazy.
Organisms like that,
like disease,
a weird articles.
So terrifying because there are these thoughtless little lifeforms that will
take over your life and on a huge percentage of people kill them.
You don't like the amount of flu deaths every year.
You would pay attention the amount of flu deaths.
Yeah,
it's a lot.
It's shit.
Scared the fucking shit out.
I've never gotten a flu shot though.
What?
I've never gotten the flu.
Never had the flu ever.
Never,
ever.
It's amazing.
Isn't that crazy?
What do you we do you,
are you like super healthy with no,
I'm actually the opposite.
I'm very,
very unhealthy in my diet and never got the flu.
I never got a flu shot either.
To do so much a bottle.
You,
I wonder if that,
I wonder what that is.
You have excellent genes.
You have an excellent immune system.
What are you,
um,
HPV
human pussy warm
now.
What,
what a nationality are you?
Uh,
my mom was born in Israel and uh,
my dad is just like hardy stark and weird,
like can't be an American.
Yeah.
I don't know what it is.
No,
because my parents had gotten the flu a bunch of times.
Israelis,
that's some healthy stock man.
Those are survivors.
There's some tough fucking people come out of Israel,
you know,
tough women.
It's very,
yeah,
very different than what we associate with like American Jewish women.
Like the stereotype is what,
like kind of whiny and like,
yeah,
we've,
we've got a mate,
you're going to make us late.
Like very motherly Israeli women are just very much like,
I'm right.
You're wrong.
There's the commercial though that they thought it was something.
So not buying this at all.
Not even
the fact that this guy doesn't know that that's rubber or some sort of squid are
either completely retarded or this is bullshit.
And I'm going with,
this is bull look Damon measuring
this is a joke.
This guy's an idiot.
Yeah.
What is it like just looking at their treat people look at her.
She's on TV and her and that's sewer grease that they have it in.
Dude.
This is like their version of self parody.
It's got a gutter oil.
That's great.
Yeah.
I don't buy it for a fucking,
so it's like got like warts on it.
It's hit the road
that's been worn for our country.
That's amazing that you've never had the flu.
I don't think I've ever the mellow.
Yeah,
buddy.
I've never had it.
And,
um,
yeah,
I,
I just,
I really,
I now I can't get flu shots.
I feel like,
I feel like if I get a flu shot,
I'm just going to go,
I don't think you need to get a flu shot.
And the flu shots are tricky because they're very,
like this year was particularly ineffective.
Like even my doctor was mocking it this year because it's so strong now.
So no,
just a,
they've failed.
It's like they,
they make these calculations based on whatever strains are out there and then
they'd develop a vaccine for that strain of the flu.
But this year was like completely ineffective.
Like oh,
totally effective.
And like 20% of the cases.
So like a lot of people that got the flu shot still wound up getting the flow.
People I know they've got the flow.
Yeah.
I mean there's no guarantee.
But here's one thing you should fucking do.
Folks get goddamn fascinated.
There's a measles outbreak at Disneyland because these fucking people think that
you don't have to vaccinate your kids.
Like there's other protocols.
Like maybe you might think that like giving your kid 26 injections when they're
born is kind of fucked up and there's others,
there's doctors that agree with you,
but there's almost no doctors that agree that you should never get vaccinated.
Why?
What's their reason?
They're just like,
it's Kinda don't want vaccines,
but there's certain drugs like polio and shit like that that's been almost
almost completely eradicated because of vaccines.
Like it's,
there's real science behind vaccine polio is making a comeback.
Yeah.
I heard polio is coming back as Holly Holly was coming back and all this is
because people don't want to violate any vaccines.
You know?
It's so easy.
It's so quick.
It's like it's so you get an autism for some people that believe that.
Yeah.
There's also some people that book,
well here's what's crazy.
There's people that can eat certain foods that you would have no problem with
and they get really sick.
Like people that have nut allergies,
like my kid goes to school and they make sure you have like we are and no nuts
school.
They have like you can't bring nuts in your,
in your food.
You can't bring like snacks that have nuts in them.
You can't do it because some kids,
they'll eat those fucking things and they just die.
So some people,
if you inject the same thing and a thousand people,
you might have 999 people that have zero problem with it at all.
But one person has a real reaction.
And the question becomes,
do we change this drug that's so beneficial to all the 909,
nine people?
Because one person has an adverse reaction,
one biological anomaly as it were.
So that's,
no,
you can't,
I mean,
obviously you can't,
that's what doctors are running into.
And then there's also,
there's a lot of suspicion of pharmacological greed.
You know,
that these people that are making the money,
these pharmacy companies that they're just greedy as fuck and they want,
you could get by with like three injections,
but they want you to get 20 because the amount of money that they'll earn,
it's substantially more if you get 20 if you mandate that every kid has to get
20 injections.
Yeah,
I mean it's,
it's crazy to me that,
that people are just like not doing it.
It's so scary because these,
you know,
you could get like a serious disease that we've eradicated.
It could get hold again and then if enough people are not vaccinated against
that disease,
it can be a fucking real issue.
Diseases.
Scary.
Terrifying.
Man.
That's scary.
I didn't have any thing about diseases.
I never was worried about them.
I got an AIDS test in 1994 and I was shitting my pants,
shitting my pants.
Believe that I've gone this long without major problems.
Do you ever think about that?
Like how like crazy it is that,
that we can go this long without getting something crazy?
Yeah.
Like Ebola or,
you know,
some sort of weird cancer that no one's heard of.
What I was going to say is I never had a problem with it until I did this TV
show and I talked to this Russian guy who worked in the biological weapons
department and the Soviet Union where they had trenches filled with anthrax and
all these people that are virus experts.
We went to the,
um,
the um,
uh,
what is it called?
The center for the CDC sit down in Galveston,
Texas with the,
a four foot thick walls and they have all the worst hemorrhagic viruses
contained in that lab where they study them and try to devise vaccines and shit
for them.
The crazy space suits every,
every room has vacuums and the ceiling that pull all the air out of it in case
anything.
I mean,
there's all,
I've seen the,
I know they're not afraid of anything other than natural shit.
They're afraid of diseases.
They're afraid of diseases that just emerge on their own out of nowhere.
And their thought is it's just a matter of time where we're running and there's
like a wave behind us it's going to hit.
It's just something that's like,
what do you,
what are you,
should you get afraid of that?
You can't do anything about that.
So what,
like I wish I,
I,
I wish I was more concerned
about stuff like that.
Like it's,
it's,
it's just so crazy that I can't even,
like,
what would I do what I do to prevent it?
This is not wear a mask.
Like,
you know,
Japanese tourists.
Would you have a good immune system?
Obviously,
if you've never gotten the flu every right at a high temperature.
Oh yeah.
Have you ever shit while having a high,
you can't get a lot of stomach viruses.
I just get a lot of those.
Hmm.
I Dunno why,
but yet never,
never the flu.
Isn't that crazy?
It's amazing.
Yeah.
I'm,
I'm turning now.
I feel like I'm jinxing it.
No,
you'll be fine.
Just stay positive.
Eat Oranges and stay positive.
Someone's going to want to give me the flu now.
They're going to get really bad.
It's just weird that we share this earth with these little aliens.
They want to kill us.
I mean,
that's really what they are.
It's weird biological things you can't even see and we want to kill them.
They want,
yeah,
it's a war.
It's a war going on man.
And they crazy when they,
when they take over your body and it decomposes,
they literally eat your body.
That's what's so fucked up about it.
Right.
When they win,
it's like a bonanza.
You know,
like the,
it's a,
it's a fine day.
Take it because the best way to spread is to don't kill 'em quick.
You've got to kill him slowly.
So they spit on everything.
Cough and everybody on the subway,
that's how you spread.
But the real motherfucker diseases,
they're like dudes who are like to pump chumps like I can't wait.
They can't,
they can't help themselves.
They just want to kill you quick.
You know,
like there's some strains of the flu that that literally aren't as deadly
because they kill you so quick they can't get is what's the,
what's the craziest disease they've discovered?
Is it still anthrax?
Like what's the craziest,
well,
hemorrhagic viruses are the scariest.
Those,
they're just,
you're like in a day you're gun.
Well they get Ebola.
You could still,
I know people had Ebola and they were just like,
well,
I got fever and then I went to the doctor and like if you get it quick enough,
if they catch what it is quick enough and they get you to a real hospital and
America land of the free home of the brave.
But if you're in Africa,
you were,
that's right here.
Oh America,
right here.
I can stop respect.
No like you.
But if you're going to thatch hut roof place,
fucking Bangladesh and they tell you you have a bullet,
you're going to be shitting your pants.
They're going to like rummage through their Tupperware looking for Madison.
Nope,
we got nothing.
You know the pop the top on these things.
Look for something they could fix you with.
Nope.
They're not going to happen.
Chickens or running around on the floor.
Front of you.
I've seen chickens in little Armenia.
In Hollywood.
Yeah.
Running around.
How are your chickens and new chicken stories?
You're,
you're,
you're no,
I got to hire someone to kill the coyote.
Yeah.
I have 20 well,
I used to have 20 floor.
You live on a farm or something?
No,
I just have a big piece of property and that's great.
I have a big chicken.
My dream,
man,
it's great.
I eat fresh eggs every morning.
That's the dream.
Yeah.
They were like,
guys,
I don't know why I love the orange egg too.
They're delicious eggs.
That is the dream,
man.
I want to get a plot of land and to make food on it.
Yeah.
You know,
I've been doing that over the last few years and you're ready man.
If go down,
if the infrastructure
implodes,
you're like,
you're not though.
You could do it.
No,
because then you're dealing with all these other more than I could,
but then you're dealing with all these people that aren't ready.
So what are you gonna do?
You're gonna be doing like guy the by herself with shotgun.
All these people are starving.
No,
you're going to give them food and you're going to run dry and it's going to
suck for everybody involved.
You better off if an asteroid hits,
if it hits your fucking head,
you know,
you don't want to be like,
no,
I'll be the cards the guy live in up there.
You know,
and the remnants of a fucking shattered world.
I don't think,
I mean that apocalyptic.
I think I'm talking about like our outage.
You know what if,
what if food becomes,
I mean food is going to be scarce at some point,
right?
There's going to people,
everyone's talking about the agricultural meltdown.
Like you know,
we're not going to be able to,
to just crops and like I don't buy it.
People are going to be like killing each other for food.
Right.
I don't buy it.
No.
I think they're just not paying as much attention to crops as they would if they
had to pay more attention.
It's the same thing what we're talking about earlier.
I think that,
you know,
you don't think about it cause you don't have to to think about it.
But if,
if it became a real issue and the government started putting massive amounts of
resources to growing crops for all the country,
they'd put their funds into that.
Halliburton gets behind it.
They have giant government contracts to grow crops in a fucking crops growing
everywhere.
You know,
they would,
they would take a pipeline.
They can take a pipeline from Alaska,
right?
They can take oil.
They bring it all the way down to Arkansas.
How come they can't do that with water?
Well,
they can.
Of course they could if they wanted to do that.
I,
I feel like the whole water thing is like,
there's gotta be a way,
there's gotta be a way to it,
right?
Eventually.
Yeah.
We talked about that a couple of weeks ago.
Apparently it's like stupid expensive and it's not that efficient yet.
Right.
But one day,
yeah.
Some someone's gonna figure out a way to do it in a way that makes sense.
They're going to make money off of it and it's,
I don't think we're going to run out of food.
I think we're gonna run US space.
We're gonna run out of resources and we're going to run out of air,
we're going to fuck the air up,
or that's gotta get shit.
You look at graphs of population and like from the time of of Jesus,
or even before like the time of cavemen,
like there's been this like steady graph and then all of a sudden the industrial
revolution happens and it's like spikes.
And like we have so many more people than we can handle.
There's gotta be something,
right?
I don't understand things,
but I feel like I,
you know,
I,
I'm not speaking out of any expertise,
but something's going to happen,
right?
Well,
there's definitely a pattern,
right?
It's definitely a pattern of abuse and overuse and gluttony and you know,
pollution of the ocean,
pollution of the air.
But when they,
if they figure it out and what is the depressing part?
It's not because what I think when people have their back up against the wall,
that's when they're forced to innovate.
When they literally are forced like just like all these other things we've been
talking about.
When you're forced to recognize the fact that we're running out of food,
then the government figures out how to step and ensure the fact that people get
food.
I think there's gonna come a point until there is no such thing as waste.
The waste is going to equal energy and there'll be able to like,
when is it right now if you take,
there's new cars that are so good at emissions that when they're driving through
a polluted area like they were driving through Mexico City,
the air that comes out of the is actually
cleaner than the air that goes in.
That's a fact.
Whoa.
Yeah.
There's German cars that do that.
The Porsche nine 11 turbo.
In fact,
when you drive through Los Angeles,
if you're driving through downtown,
it's thick with fucking stinky smog.
The air coming out of the exhaust pipes is better to fucking breathe than the
air that it's taking in and it's intake.
Wow.
Yeah.
That's nuts.
So it's going to come a point in time where they could figure out how to use
that shitty air,
like use the carbon dioxide and the carbon monoxide in the air for fuel.
They just need to figure out how to extract it.
Like right now what we're doing is like we have,
there's a two step process.
You know,
you make something and that like there's like a waste product,
but that waste product is,
it's really almost an engineering issue.
It's almost like once we innovate to a point where whatever that stuff is,
like with everything will be clear.
Labeling renewable like nuclear waste or gasoline.
Like,
okay,
here's a perfect example.
People that live by,
by airplanes,
anybody lives by airports,
significant amount of people suffer lung damage of lung disease,
asthma.
It's like pretty significant.
You should never live near an airport.
Major airports especially,
well,
there's this,
there's some shit that you're breathing in,
right?
But why is it out there?
How do you get it?
What it,
what is that stuff?
Is it flammable?
Is it,
can it be used as fuel?
How can it be extracted from the methane?
Right?
I Dunno what the fuck it is,
but there is methane,
but that's what about dialogic about the fact that they're a cloud wifi waves
and cellular waves all everywhere.
That's true.
There's like so much stuff that we,
it we create that is bad for us.
Well,
that's not necessarily true.
I don't think they've ever proven that's why Wifi is bad for you or that
cellular is bad for you.
It just feels bad.
It's bad for bugs.
It's really bad for bees.
Is it?
Yeah.
It's real bad for bees.
Bees.
Apparently their communication system gets completely fucked up by Wifi,
Wifi and by cellular networks.
It's like they're hearing and next door neighbor that won't stop banging and it
never goes away.
I don't think they can live.
They can live,
but they're like,
ah.
Everywhere around them as people,
lol,
you know?
Fuck it.
Yeah.
They just hear everything we're saying.
They probably don't just hear it.
They hear all the porn we're watching on the Internet.
They hear like everything through the airways.
Can you send a text?
It's like,
ah,
she's
flying in a row.
You ever go somewhere that has no cell phone?
No cell phone,
no Wifi.
Oh yeah.
It feels so quiet.
It feels amazing.
Like,
yeah cause Elan in the,
I've actually,
yeah,
only
in the last year I've made a point of being away from my phone like totally away
from my phone,
not just in the other room,
but like if I go on a hike,
I leave the phone in the car.
Like,
because like we are never alone.
We're never like unreachable.
It's true.
Like even if you're alone,
you're not alone because you're like,
Oh let me check out what friends are tweeting at me.
She'd just turn it off though if you're going on a hike because then when a
mountain going to be,
but even if I turn it off,
I feel like I still have the option.
I just want to be totally away from it and it feels great and then I get back
and I'm like,
Ooh,
I have like four emails.
You know what?
I know what you mean.
Isn't it funny?
We're so scared to be away from my phone.
Like something bad's going to happen.
Like,
how often do you actually need is a phone.
You know what's going to happen.
So rarely do you actually need it to stay alive.
So rarely.
But like if you go on a hike,
you like pop better,
bring the fucking phone.
Just foaming times hiked.
Yeah,
like a hundred times.
Nothing happens.
You'd be fine.
I've never,
I've never been attacked on a hike.
Well,
when I lived in Colorado,
I used to pack heat.
I used to walk Karen,
it would drive me crazy while I was walking in these mountain line infested
woods.
Fuck that.
And even if they don't kill people all the time,
if you were there,
the one like the guy in Cupertino where his daughter got a,
or a son rather got attacked by mountain line.
If that guy had a gun,
he could have shot it.
Not even at the animal,
just shot it near the animal and that thing would run and you're done.
It's over.
You know,
they hear a boom.
It fucking just take off.
Freaks him out.
But how often does your kid get attacked by a mountain lion?
If you live in Cupertino and you're that guy and you're walking down that road
and it happens,
all those numbers are not comforting.
Yeah.
It doesn't matter
guys.
Son has been attacked to wife is screaming,
why didn't you bring your gun?
How often does it
fucking happened?
It happens,
but I mean if gonna Chunk taken out of his ass forever,
he's going to be that boy in the locker room.
They make fun of,
you know,
those fake asses where they take the fat from other parts of their body and they
put it in the bud.
It started real.
Yeah,
it's real.
It started in a Columbia,
I believe,
or Brazil.
Most Colombians or Brazilians ha girls have that.
No,
it's,
that's how common is something pretty common.
More than half.
It's Pr.
It's pretty cool.
So they take fat out of like,
oops and Jamie,
you might even be able to find it,
but they take it out of their side and they put in there,
but,
but lately they've been noticing that the fat doesn't takes in,
it goes down their legs and it makes their ankles super fat.
And so people in Columbia where these like,
like ugg boots type things are really popular because so many girls I've had
this problem,
it goes down to their ankles.
Yeah.
Like little kids site there but doesn't tense everything that he does.
Columbia Little Kids Angle,
uh,
Columbia just by luck or whatever.
So what I would just take,
I know that they're doing fat translation to the buttocks and for steadily
enhancement.
If you Google anything,
you'll find it longterm results.
Wow.
The result of the buttock augmentation show that there are oh 0.5 1.0 centimeter
reduction at two months.
Oh,
okay.
They're just talking about the efficacy conclusion.
The hypotheses is that fat applied graphs are real.
Graphs was demonstrated and not only the graphs real,
but they are able to live and they persist with the patient's growing.
If the patient gained weight to the glutes area and losing circumference when
losing weight.
So what they're saying is it works.
They're saying that that fat,
when you transplant it to the ass,
it does make your ass thicker and that,
what are you doing?
What was that?
I'm reading it.
If,
fuck,
how dare you.
They're saying that it makes it that no damage to the graft was observed.
So they,
this,
they're saying that it's fine.
It works.
It's like skin graphs,
but they actually can make your ass fatter and they can make another party.
You thinner man.
But it probably comes out all lumpy.
No,
I mean,
how are they,
how do they get it all smooth and perfect?
I mean,
I'm sure there's a more of a process than just stuffing it in.
I would assume they put it in a blender or something.
They must like dilute it somehow.
Right?
I don't know man.
Well,
they're injecting it.
Right.
So it's not where I want to have fun too.
Like look at,
um,
botched but enlargement surgery.
Whoa,
whoa.
Hello.
Holy Shit.
That works.
That's incredible and cool.
But Oh my God,
look at that.
But with the Thong,
well,
there's no difference the same,
but while there's a lot of bullshit with these things for sure,
but augmentation and [inaudible].
Great.
Well let's go to that page.
Let's find out what they do.
Also,
one of them's like more in polar and Paige not image.
There you go.
Um,
the,
um,
the ones where they have implants though,
that's scary.
That's where they're taking like a hunk of something,
like a fucking,
some sort of a,
it's like a,
it's like a rubber thing and they're sticking it in there.
Isn't it crazy that no matter what context,
when I see a nice bud,
I don't even see the whose face it is.
I'm just like instantly a little bit turned on like you just see a bigger,
but why?
Why is that?
Does anyone ever,
because it's like more better for children,
especially the hips to waist ratio.
When you see a woman with a wide hips,
you think,
oh,
I was just thinking immediately like,
okay.
We strongly advise against surgical butt implants.
If your office work environment requires excessive sitting over eight to 10
hours a day after surgery,
the doctors will advise you not to sit directly in your reshaped but for at
least a few days to avoid any unneeded stress to the operated areas during your
recovery.
Yeah.
What the fuck,
man.
I like Peggy and HR can't get it done.
Yeah.
If you're going to sit in front of a desk,
if you've seen the implants that have failed,
now what those implants are talking about,
Jamie,
this is fat.
No,
this is,
yeah,
this is an implants.
I think it's silicone,
right?
Or selling homes,
but versus fat transfers.
Here you go.
If your butt area has began sagging a bit and you're slightly older than age
than a surgical lift will probably be the most appropriate surgical.
But lift and Thailand is performed by removing fat tissue followed by the
tightening of the surrounding skin,
the tissue in your buttocks as normally excised.
I love that.
Slashed cut.
That's the same thing and that's like punched slash hit near the blood crease to
give a natural look with minimal scars.
This amazing new technique.
Lee's an unknown.
Possible scar.
Knew your buttocks crease.
Yeah.
That's noticeable.
It's fuck.
You see it in porn films when girls are getting diaried.
Yeah.
You see this weird scar where their butt cheeks meet their tank.
I've never seen it.
It technique is very popular with Australian and American clients who save 40%
when compared to the prices back home.
But you get 100% more diseases.
The new technique is offered in Bangkok and works by carefully sawing away,
no cutting away tissue near the intersection of your button lower back.
I mean,
you know,
it feels like a decent thing to do.
This is supposedly what a Kim Kardashian guide she got the Brazilian butt lift
is,
which is what all the Brazilian girls supposedly have is why you always go and
Brazilians have great ass.
No,
this is,
I mean that's been confirmed,
right?
She has something and so it was Nicki Minaj,
she looks way different than she used to live.
They live with her but you're still looked like and she also doesn't look like
that.
Like,
like she would have that muscular legs.
Like it's not like she's,
her legs are these thick fucking like a Serena Williams type athlete legs.
No,
no.
They're like,
she's got a big old,
oh Geez Louise.
Good Lord.
Oh my goodness.
That's a blue day.
But that's an athlete's.
But like you look at Serena's body like Jesus,
that's how fucking that's a performer.
You know,
like her,
her body can move and ways.
Kim Kardashians just looks like she's wearing a diaper.
Like just weird.
You know what I mean?
It's like this red stitch.
It's got a load.
It doesn't make sense.
It doesn't make sense with their legs.
Well there's some images of her like,
like you see those photos like Kim Kardashians breaks the Internet.
Her ass looks fantastic,
like spectacular.
But then you see here like there's some red carpet video of her walking around
with it.
Here.
It's weird as fuck cause it doesn't match the rest of her legs.
Like it's way better to have a smaller,
but that fits your legs than it is to have these thin legs.
In this,
I actually have the opposite.
I don't have a butt like I have any,
but I'm making us look at your,
but I'm not having any,
I don't have,
yeah,
I don't really have a,
but should I show,
I mean it's like,
well it just looks like you don't work out.
You don't work out.
Right.
Do you lift weights with your,
but yeah.
Do you have a seat and it all,
does it,
um,
don't like when you're,
when you're lifting weights,
do you do squats or anything with your legs?
No,
I shut it all it is,
but I do a lot of like,
like curls for the girls running and crossings.
But running is really good for your legs but it's not so good or bad.
But like if you watch marathon runners,
they're in,
they don't have like fitbits.
It's just not a lot of like jumping up.
I know I've always had an issue with that.
There's always like pants don't fit right.
It would slide down,
you can fix it.
Don't get lazy and get a butt job.
It's getting batch jobs together.
That's the boy's Day.
You imagine that became a thing
but it played,
they would take off her and little,
you know,
fat things here and so it would actually look better here and then it would make
her look together at the same time.
You would be so self conscious on stage cause it looks like you're wearing a
fucking diaper.
It looks like you like imagine I just got a huge,
but oh my God,
if butts on guys became big,
he tied the end of your shorts tight to your leg and just filled your shorts
with shit.
And that's what it looks like.
But I have no jokes about it.
It's just a huge,
but you don't even bring it up.
I had a friend that had a huge ass and he was massively self conscious about it
because he wasn't overweight too much in his upper body.
He was very pear shaped.
Whereas upper bottle use arms look totally normal and then there's upper body
look fairly overweight and then it got to his gut and it distended on the sides.
And then his ass was enormous.
His ass and legs where he carried all of his weight.
So people who look like you know,
and when you get in arguments to people,
they'll go look at your fucking ass dude.
Like I,
if I would look like you,
I would be grumpy too.
Like people would get really mean with him because of his,
but that's what I think.
You know there's certain guys who look okay fat,
you know like there's certain guys that are like,
oh you're a fat guy,
you look great fat.
And then there's some guys that look really,
really bad fat and I think it's,
if you're,
if your lower half is in shape and your upper half is not like Jonah Hill has
that I have that.
If I'm like I used to be way fatter like,
and it looks weird because my,
I have skinny legs and then you then it looks like you just heard this like half
fat Minotaur where people are allowed to have a fat gut.
But if you have like a fairly normal guy but an enormous fat ass and fat pigs
and people like what the fuck?
Like yeah,
you're weirdly proportioned and I don't understand you because you don't fit in
my database.
Yeah.
Like we have a database of pot bellies.
Like you see a guy with a pot belly,
you don't even blink because we all have a database.
It's not like a weird thing,
but if you see a girl with a pot belly,
you want to protect things,
either pregnant or a fucking weird body.
When the weird body freaks you out.
Like even if you have no desire to have sex with this woman,
if a woman comes near you and she's got a giant Joey Diaz sides belly,
you're kind of freaked out.
But his body makes sense.
It makes sense on his body.
Like you look at it and you're like,
Oh,
you're that guy.
I know that guy.
My Dad has hung out with that guy.
You know,
this is a database.
This is the face of that guy.
But if you have a guy that has like really
skinny legs,
like super skinny legs,
but like Ralphie May's arms.
Yeah,
it's really weird.
What the fuck is going on?
I don't understand what I'm saying.
I gotta get Outta here.
I'm too weirded out.
I gotta get Outta here,
man.
Yeah,
like chess night is over.
New Weird bodies will freak us out.
Like things like we have like a database withdraw from it and when,
when when something doesn't fit in there,
it's just like up to weird.
Got to go.
I turned down sex ones because this girl had a square,
but where it was like kind of burned down sex because of it.
Yeah,
because it just freaked me.
I don't,
you know,
it freaked me out because she had no waste for one thing and then her butt was
completely flat,
almost indented that.
It's just when you saw it you're just like,
ah.
So you were like on top.
I actually would was like,
all right,
well you know what?
I got to go.
I just took off right before bed.
I could never go and I caught her sponge Bob Square pants because I think it was
just,
it was too gross and call it tour face.
No,
no,
I just put it on.
He just tweeted about it up.
Just put it on her face with her full name.
I just gave out her address.
Geo tagged it.
If you're looking for a flat,
this is your spot.
This is your pirate map.
I feel like if I'm already there,
I mean it's like,
it's so great that someone's willing to be there and do it.
And then weird that like,
it probably would feel just as good,
like the,
as far as the sensation,
but you wouldn't be as a rouse so it wouldn't be as good.
And it's all just based on the shape of the body.
And people get angry at that man.
They say you're shallow and you know,
this is a really like surface way of thinking.
It's so immature and so stupid,
but those people are all fat.
That's why they're saying that hot chicks,
a great bodies,
they never,
they never feel like that.
When you tell a girl like,
God,
your body is amazing.
They never go,
oh,
you just are attracted to,
I got to say the hazing.
I gotta be the devil's advocate here.
And I gotta say,
I've,
I've been with,
look,
I've been with a lot of one
double digit double digit women.
Um,
and uh,
I've been with some,
you know,
like very good looking and some very average and,
whatever.
I think I've actually been more aroused by more normal looking women.
Then later you'll probably more models cause I'm more comfortable.
I feel like I have less to prove.
Right.
Like there's like,
it's also like there's,
there's something about like a normal looking body that is a little more
attractive to me.
You have a buddy who would go to strip clubs,
new to always want to like talk to the girls that were overweight like that.
What he was actually tracking overweight.
I mean,
you know,
well overweight for a strip club is know for sure.
But yeah,
I mean what kind of overweighted they're going to get like 2030 pounds
overweight.
But he would go for the big girls because they're easy.
But he wasn't even trying to like have sex with him.
He just was attracted to that and he'd want to get dancers stem because he said
it would make sense that they would date him.
Oh yeah.
That's what you want.
That's what every guy wants to strip clubs.
You want,
you want girl to like you.
Yeah.
Any guy who denies that is lying.
Like you want the girl to be like,
you know,
oh my God,
I want to leave with him.
She's a 10 she's like,
oh,
hi sweetie.
Yeah,
it's all,
it's all of that.
So fucking gross.
I want her to be in love.
I wonder to come back please.
Barry,
are you going to be wanting to take her out of that town?
Peri Peri telling me you want to take her out of Kokomo,
Indiana.
Give you dances for free.
Oh yeah.
Just stay bearing.
I'll stay.
Stay Joe Rogan.
Yeah.
They don't want you to,
they don't want you to like no guy.
Like even though people will pay for prostitution,
no guy would prefer that.
What?
You would prefer someone to be attracted to you.
You wouldn't want a girl who was putting on an act where you know specifically
that she doesn't want to be there.
You'd want her to be really good salmon porno.
Like you don't want a girl who you know is acting well.
That's why we were things that are so rude.
Unless they're so good,
they can trick you.
That's great.
Yeah.
But you don't want to see the eye.
You don't want to see the act
comic or like a fucking magician where you could see their hands moving,
you know?
Yeah.
You're getting a different girl every time and you can play around with
different races and ages and,
yeah.
What I'm saying is if,
what would you prefer though?
That's not what I'm saying.
Well,
I mean let's engineer 30,
or do you want one car or would you rather have keys to the dealership and he
just,
just pick whatever you want.
No,
it's not.
We're talking about people you fuck.
Oh my God.
Yeah.
I Dunno.
I,
I got,
um,
a prostitute when I was,
I mean,
this is,
I'm going to be on Ra Shell and I talk about this story when I was in Atlantic
city and I got a hooker hooker's from Atlantic city show.
No.
Is it an HBO?
Yeah.
At least do an HBO show.
Those were so depressing.
Ooh,
I remember trying to masturbate to those when I was a kid.
I'm not real.
Sex would come on very real sex and it would be like just old people tickling
each other and you're just like,
what?
Like for a second there would be like,
oh,
this is kinda hot.
And then they would just have these like fat lesbians slapping each other and
you're like,
this is really weird.
Do you think that if,
if prostitution wasn't so chastise with prostitution was legal,
then it would be like going and getting massages?
It would be so normal and it wouldn't feel dirty or bad at all.
I bet.
I bet that's,
if it was legal,
prostitution was completely legal.
Okay.
And these places were totally above ground.
It was just like going to a massage parlor.
If you go to a massage parlor,
now you go,
hello.
Everybody's greets you.
They're all nice.
You don't feel weird about it.
You put on your robe,
you go there,
some stranger rubs your neck and rubs your back.
You feel so much better and you actually have a wonderful time with them.
It's,
it's,
it's fine because it's not guilty.
But if it was guilty for you to be in your underwear and have some lady dig or
elbow,
elbow into your back,
you'd have all these weird connections with it would only be able to go to shady
places to get that massage.
It would be like this Weirdo.
I don't think it has anything to do with the law.
I think the law
has nothing to do with it.
I think it's our weirdness with sex.
I think it's right.
Right,
but,
but that weirdness was,
sex is connected to the fact that it's illegal on how channel.
Because then you're,
then you would say like,
oh,
what if you know,
I didn't have to pay for it.
What if I told my girlfriend,
oh,
you know,
I'm just going to have sex with this girl.
I know that's totally unrelated because we're talking about you're paying for a
service for something.
Yeah,
we're talking about prostitution now.
I know,
but I think it's the stigma of the sex of it.
Not The law,
because it's not really like,
no,
I don't think it's considered like,
you know,
you don't feel like you're breaking out.
What of you think you're using masturbation,
you're using her to masturbate though.
You're not like you're not having sex.
I mean,
you're in and out in like seven minutes.
Explain that again so that you don't think it's about,
so you're saying that if it was legal that it would remove some of the stigma
attached to it.
The stigma by who though?
Well,
buy most people who think of it as being a dirty thing.
I mean most people,
they don't want their daughter to become a prostitute.
They don't want their ex girlfriends to become prostitutes.
They don't,
I mean it's just like this thing.
You don't want to be stripping angle,
but there's a stigma to that.
There is.
There's certainly is.
But this is like,
I think it's because we're living in this country where weirder about sex than
we are about anything and no question,
but don't you think that part of that weirdness is to do with the law?
The fact that we legislate whether or not you can hardly eat and no one has a
problem with it.
You can go have sex with anybody you want,
but for some reason other we can legislate whether or not you have sex with
anybody you want.
If they give you money,
which is crazy.
I mean,
it's crazy.
Yeah.
I mean it is crazy.
There's a lot of crazy,
I think,
I'm not saying that gambling is illegal is crazy,
too crazy,
ridiculous.
I'm not saying people should,
you know,
go get proud.
Salad should be prostitutes,
but you should be able to do whatever the fuck you want to do.
Well,
you know what's crazy about it?
He's like,
how open we are about calling them escorts were just like,
that's fine.
Well,
they get like you go into the yellow pages,
even not even in Vegas,
like places where it's totally like in New York and there's just escort service,
escort service.
Like who is really under the impression that they're not having sex?
Yeah.
There's a few people that don't like this weird legal gray area are there?
Yeah,
there's like every,
it's like every cop,
every one who makes the law just like fine.
Well,
there's some weird thing where they're allowed to go out with you and have sex
if they choose to.
But if it says,
if it's like written down in paper,
at the end of this date,
I'm going to Suck Your Dad Kinda and I'm going to rub your balls,
which is nuts.
It's crazy.
Well,
it's just stupid that you could tell a person what to do and not to do.
And the idea of beings that if it's legal,
like everybody's going to go into prostitution or everyone's going to go get
prostitutes and the marriages will crumble.
And that's not true.
If you look at statistics in Australian,
it's legal,
like legalized prostitution is actually led to a lower rate of divorce in
Australia.
Yeah,
well it's legal in some places here,
right?
Sort of one area in Carson city.
Yeah.
It's like way the fuck out in the middle of nowhere.
Not Pretty hypocritical.
Right.
It's weird.
It's just weird telling people what they can do.
You know what?
I think a lot of it is to a politician would never stand behind changing that
law.
Like I think everyone thinks it's kinda crazy.
But I don't think to get a politician to be like,
I'm fighting for prostitute rights.
They all use them.
Who's going to do that?
Well,
that's one of the issues with that guy in New York.
Um,
the,
the guy who was the mayor of New York or the governor of New York,
and they found out that he was using prostitutes,
Spitzer,
Eliot Spitzer.
He was the fucking governor.
He was busting people for prostitution while he was using prostitutes.
I mean,
he's just,
he's a God damn target.
But that guy,
like,
you know,
I mean,
he was the top of the heap as far as politicians in New York state and he was
using prostitute.
Yeah.
I mean,
is that,
I'm speaking most of them out and say,
look,
let's get real with this.
He couldn't,
yeah.
Line would stand behind that.
Who was with me,
crickets,
crickets.
Because he just comes out and tries it.
I mean,
there's a place that my buddy told me about in,
uh,
in Seattle,
let's say Seattle,
he just went,
that is a marijuana store on one side.
And on the other side,
it's just a whorehouse and it's,
you can go in with your Visa Card,
get your weed,
get your pussy,
and God bless America in an hour,
45 minutes.
God bless America.
That's how it should
did.
You should be able to do whatever the fuck you want.
Like there's a law that they're passing in some state,
I forgot some backwards as state where they're,
they're going to make certain tattoos and body piercings illegal.
Like they're going to be able to decide for what reasons.
Exactly.
They're just,
it's
thanks.
Have a reason.
Like I once had an argument,
someone over like seat belt laws,
right?
Should you,
should you be allowed to wear a seatbelt if you want to or not want to?
Right,
right.
But then you,
you,
you think if people get injured all the time,
you're dealing with higher health insurance costs.
You're dealing with way more flooded hospitals with car accidents and deaths.
Less dumb people,
more dumb people dead.
Other people will suffer from you being dumb.
Whereas a tattoo,
no one else will suffer from that.
Yeah.
I don't know what the fucking logic behind it is.
I think it's just they want to change the appearance of the young folks.
They see these kids with these giants,
your holes,
that's what it is.
You know,
it freaks them out.
Each kids these days is can't live and let live,
and a lot of older people especially,
they don't want to live and let live.
They want everybody to be just like them.
And when the fucking God damn kids not spiky hearings and they're crazy hair and
he'd just get upset and you want to stop face tattoos,
like who you know,
come on,
you can't.
They,
it's,
it's not a good thing to do,
but you can't.
You can't stop it.
You know?
It's not good to tattoo stars all over your fucking forehead,
but if you want to do it,
that's your thing.
Go ahead and do it.
You can't stop people from doing what they want to do because it's not,
you're right.
They might like it.
They might see the world that totally legitimately differently than you do and
they might want to look like that lizard man do split his tongue and tattooed
his face.
Green had implants,
dermal implants and his eyebrows.
He's getting somebody to
the show.
I met him,
he was in front row and the audience in Austin,
Texas and one of my shows and I was like,
how much attention do you want,
man,
you sit in front row and he looked like a fucking lizard person.
He didn't,
he didn't.
He get arrested for it.
Oh,
that's a different guy.
I think he got his eye.
There's a guy who got his eyeballs tattooed black who?
Who recently got arrested for assault.
Oh God.
Yeah.
Good luck convincing the jury that you're cool.
The ear thing pisses me off when girls have their ears stretched out.
I met,
yeah,
I met this girl and in Vegas that beautiful,
but then her ears were that big open like where she had the big plug in the
middle of it and you know that girl and 20 years is not going to have that inner
ear.
You can fix it.
Can you fix it?
Tied in a knot,
cut that,
cut a section off it off,
and they put together and they sell it.
And you'll have scars in the bottom of your ear.
Labioplasty on your ears.
Right,
exactly what it's like.
Yeah.
It's like,
yeah,
it's not a fix it.
They can,
I mean,
it doesn't look good,
but it won't look unbelievably freakish.
Yeah,
you could,
you could correct most things,
right,
that you can correct,
but there's a dude that I know he's got,
his shit is like this big and he does Jujitsu,
so he's got a tape his ears up.
William does Jujitsu.
Hundreds.
It takes the plug out and then he tapes.
He puts tape on his ears.
Yeah,
it's nuts.
It's just people are weird with those things,
man.
But you can't stop them from doing it.
They like it.
What do you gear if you don't like it,
don't do it to yourself.
See that passing a law that prevents passed.
It's passed.
Yeah.
It's past this.
Uh,
hold on,
let me,
let me find it.
You know,
in Europe there's like a lot of laws.
There's laws with naming kids.
You can't name a kid anything you want and not the certain England.
There's a law that makes you,
um,
makes you,
you have to practice archery for two hours every Sunday.
It's like on the books,
like every male has to pray.
It's like one of those laws has been there since like the 16 hundreds.
Everyone's dying of arrows to the head.
Yeah.
It's in,
it's in Pennsylvania apparently that this uh,
this legislation,
yeah.
There's laws in New York of dancing is illegal in certain blocks.
Gll Really?
Yeah.
There's areas where you can't dance dance from like the 1800,
some sort of crazy law.
Footloose can't be gay.
There's a lot of areas of can't.
It's illegal to be gay.
I have gay sex.
Yeah.
That's sodomy illegal.
It's blowjobs are illegal in a lot of states.
Yeah.
There's a,
I'm trying to find this fucking legislation.
It's,
I'm looking under the wrong date because this is all,
uh,
in 2012 at some new one because I just tweeted a few days ago,
see if you can find that shit,
Jamie.
I don't know where it is,
but the idea of anybody telling you,
you know you can't wear those pants.
You can't do that to your hair.
You can't do that to your nose.
I saw a picture of a guy who had the tip of his nose removed.
Have you seen that?
That's a new thing.
Those extreme body modification guys are doing.
Yeah.
Have you seen it?
I have,
yeah.
Fuck.
I've seen the forehead.
Donuts.
People get those huge foreheads,
but they can get that taken off.
They can get your news,
your nose put back,
but then when they do that,
they cut your fucking scalp open.
Slide that thing down your fucking head and leave that big horseshoe in the
center.
It's awesome.
They must get so much.
It's probably get a lot of Dick Dick with holes in it.
Barbs and stuff.
He got a lot of like those,
those dicks with dudes like they put those bolts and their dicks.
Yeah,
they have like piercings all over their Cox.
My friend had a,
he got a shitty lip job where they're supposed to pierce it,
like underneath all the shitty live jobs by the way.
Yeah.
But anytime he sneezes it just squirts out like a fire hose out of his mouth.
My God,
no.
Yeah,
there's like ones,
but they removed pieces of their cheek.
You can see in their mind
they put a hole in there as a whole more and more and more until it becomes like
you could literally look in and see their gums and their teeth.
It's horrific.
I think people have mental illnesses and you know,
it just manifests in different ways.
Body dysmorphia is real shit,
man.
It's like those crazy women that never think there.
Of course breasts are big enough,
they get nuts like they can,
they can't see it and they just want a bigger and bigger and bigger,
but that's what they want.
Who Cares?
They're probably crazy anyway.
You know,
if you,
I wouldn't want to hang out with them,
but if you want to and you want to go do it,
who gives a shit?
It doesn't hurt anyone else.
Yeah.
I mean,
it's weird.
It's weird.
All the choices that people make,
you know,
people are strange,
like stylistic choices.
People are very strange,
but when people try to life,
great.
Yeah.
When people try to legislate against that,
create laws that say anything like did they could easily make a law that say no
more massage.
You know,
if someone,
if someone decided to make a law that says no more massage,
I would be fucking God damn furious.
Especially colleges are,
are incredible.
I've only started getting them recently and they're like,
it's mass.
This world makes you feel so much better.
Just relaxes you.
Loosens all your muscles up.
Everything falls into place better.
You feel healthier,
less stressed out.
Yeah.
I got a really weird one recently where they like beat me up.
They basically liked this more than just like beat me.
Yeah.
Like a Thai massage and she was just standing on me.
It's time massage sauce.
She had her foot in my butt at some oil.
Yeah.
Did you stretch you out to like pull your legs and stuff?
Oh yeah.
It was to stop bumping into that ouchy loud.
Did you get the prostate massage also though?
Have you ever had that?
No.
I've never gotten any of those like happy I me,
I've never even been offered that.
That's not a happy ending.
That's just like an actual part of massage that a lot of places our finger in
your back,
they just rub around.
We went to never hurt.
Nobody.
Massages your prostate and irregular fucking massage.
I've had many sizes that were not whack off massage places and then they rub
your bottle would rub their,
put their thumb on it and they just rub around your butthole muscles around your
asshole cannot be real
prostate massage like a finger in it with a little finger now.
Shut the fuck up.
I swear to God,
I swear to God I go to a lot.
I go to like,
yeah,
those are not regular massage parlors or jerk off places,
but this is a place that didn't jerk me off.
This isn't like if Nora,
they rub your butthole.
It's either time massage or Chinese massage that the guy off.
Pretty normal where they white tees.
Yeah.
Let me just finish them off.
Well,
it's weird that we have spots where you're not supposed to touch.
You know?
And for women it's abreast,
but for man that it doesn't matter at all.
You could rub a guy's breasts,
you brought rubber guys packs and it does absolutely nothing.
Like no one cares.
Oh yeah.
She rubbed the hell out of a woman can have your arm and just push down on
breasts and manipulate them.
And you know,
nobody freaks out.
But even that much like a stripper,
like I wanted to feel like she liked me,
you know what I mean?
Like I wanted to feel like I was different than the other massage.
Of course.
You know,
like I was better at Cha taking a massage.
Yeah,
of course.
And she did.
And I'm dating and she's my wife.
She's my dream girl.
She's the one,
my one of a kind.
She stopped rubbing all those other dudes.
Yeah.
Eventually
lucky people should be able to do anything they want.
If they want to suck dicks for money,
they can do it.
As long as there's a camera in the room,
see how hypocritical that is?
If you wanted to film it and make a living by putting that on the Internet and
have a camp and the guy could still come in and pay you,
he could still come in and pay you 500 bucks.
You blow him on camera and then look,
we just made porn.
Oh,
okay.
You made porn.
Did you get all your tests?
It really is.
It's just antiquated from the time where there would be prostitute areas where
they would walk around and it would be bad for business business or the
neighborhood and you have to see it would be CD,
but you can't change it now.
There's no politician that's going to change that,
but they will still arrest people.
That's where it gets really weird.
It's like your rest has his arrest number paying for pleasure.
Oh,
it's,
I mean the same thing as gambling.
I grew up,
my dad was a bookie.
I wasn't,
yeah,
he was arrested several times for it.
No,
she didn't.
Well,
what sports betting sports betting.
Yeah.
He was involved with the Gambino crime family.
Was this like,
I like how weird was that was weird.
I didn't know.
I didn't know about it at all until I was older.
Wow.
And then I found out that he didn't know at all.
I didn't know at all.
No,
he was just,
he did,
he was like,
he's got a job.
You know,
he told everyone he was an accountant for me.
Is that your phone's vibrating like that?
It's probably just,
you know,
it's the old ball and chain.
Would you,
when you were a kid,
would you wonder like,
hey,
where the fuck is done and he'd get arrested?
No.
I would wonder why he would promise these.
Like he would promise like,
you know,
a trip to California and then all of a sudden he'd be like,
I don't have the money.
Or He'd be like,
I'm in jail and I didn't know I'm in jail.
And he didn't know why.
No,
I didn't know why.
I didn't know why he wouldn't say he was in jail.
He would just be like,
I can't see you this week.
Oh,
it would happen a few times.
But,
so he's in jail for like very short.
It was a,
he was an informant for the FBI for a little bit too.
Took down this whole ring.
Holy Shit.
Yeah,
that's dead now so I can talk about it.
Fuck yeah,
that'd be so stressful.
It was,
it was,
and he took me around with him like to do this.
He,
I remember he had to put cameras in this office and I was like,
cause you know he had,
he had shared custody so I would have to see him on weekends and he and he would
have to go on weekends and put like these little mini cameras with this FBI
dude,
Whoa,
reverend meet these guys,
these gambling guides in the back of a pizzeria in Brooklyn.
And they would all give me $50 bills.
How long did this go on for?
25 years.
For 25 years.
You were involved with your dad doing this then I found out when I was a
teenager and I started working for it and I became a book.
He also,
whoa.
That's cool.
So when,
when your dad turned state's evidence and you dad became an informant,
did you know that he had turned state's evidence?
How old were you at the time?
I was like eight.
You were eight?
Yeah,
I was real young.
So you started working for him after he became an informant?
He did.
He became a foreman.
Took down this one ring and then he started working for a different gambling
ring.
Oh my,
for a different booking office.
I'm so crazy.
It was really nuts.
What did he did?
It was so normal for me.
Oh yeah.
We talk about all the time.
I was part of the business.
At some point it started with me like I would have to dispose of evidence.
Like they were like,
my dad was like,
how do we get this kid a job?
So they would be like,
just take these trashcan trash bags and throw them in different dumpsters around
town.
Wow.
So I would take these trends and if I got caught with it,
it would be,
so,
you know,
these were like gambling slips.
These are evidence.
And then I graduated to like I,
I would,
uh,
do you ever get caught with them?
No.
No,
no,
no.
I never,
but if you did,
it would have been a big deal.
It would have been strange to have a 16 year old kid going around with the
evidence for this gambling ring.
So your dad gets busted.
He turned state's evidence,
right.
He gets his people arrested.
Apparently what happened was he was told by one of the guys,
one of the FBI guys that there's going to be a raid but we don't have enough
evidence yet so we won't arrest you or we will arrest you still,
but we won't prosecute you if you put up cameras and stuff and you get this,
you get us more evidence.
And he did.
And then the weirdest thing is they just let him go back to doing it.
Now.
Was it sanctioned?
That was the question was,
is it when they,
when he went back,
they know he was doing it and they let them know,
no,
I don't think that.
They just like monitor you forever.
They just let you go.
It was like that was it.
So he just went back to what he always did.
Went back to a different place.
How do you justify that?
Like that's had to be so weird for him to like,
arrest,
get people arrested for doing something.
He is eventually going to go and do himself.
Yeah.
I never,
you know what,
I never asked him that.
That's a weird one.
I never,
he,
he actually,
the reason he got into it to give him more in depth thought it was,
he embezzled uh,
I think $2 million from Ricoh cameras.
She is Christ.
He was the CFO of Ricoh cameras and he's a million.
He was making,
you know,
in like the mid eighties,
he was making like six,
$700,000 a year,
which is like now it's way more.
Um,
and he was a million and a half now,
right?
Yeah.
He was making a lot of money back then.
We would take limos to Atlantic city every weekend.
Whoa.
And then as the story goes,
he was just for two years,
I think,
just embezzling money.
He was just like doing shady transactions and taking money off the top.
And then he got caught when there was a new CEO and he blackmailed the CEO
because he had information on the company that they didn't want coming out.
And he got out,
but he could never work in the industry again.
So he became a gambler.
I mean a,
a bookie and a gambler.
That's crazy.
So He's,
he embezzled $2 million.
Scottfree scottfree yeah.
Wow.
Yeah,
yeah.
They were starting to get charges together and he was facing like 40 life,
almost life in prison.
He loves the craziest fucking stressful applying.
And then he,
you know,
he became a gambler.
And this was around the time my mom left and was like 86,
um,
he bet $300,000 on the red sox to win the world series in [inaudible] 86.
Oh my God.
In the world series.
You remember that?
It was a good buck and he lost 300,000,
which was like most of their savings.
And my mom left him the next day.
Jesus Christ,
man,
no wonder why you're a comic.
I'm like,
no wonder.
I thought it was so cool,
man.
When I,
when I got involved in it,
it was like the Sopranos was on TV.
It was like my dad's a gangster,
but he was,
he was this like fat Jewish guy.
Like he wasn't,
he wasn't involved in any of that.
Like he knew guys that were like strong men for the,
for the guy for,
you know,
really connected.
What did he die from?
Colon cancer.
Oh,
it was probably a lot of it due to stress right now.
He was,
he treated his body like crap.
He basically didn't exist for the last 10 years of his life.
He didn't pay taxes.
He wasn't on the Mat.
He didn't have id and he was just like,
totally.
He kept going.
He didn't have a bank account,
50,000 in cash above his bed on a headboard,
witness protection program styles that what was going on?
No,
he just didn't want to pay taxes.
He didn't want to pay tax on any of his money.
So you can't like exist really.
So did he know that he would still health insurance?
So he didn't have any of that stuff and you didn't take care of his body.
And then he got sick and it was already like stage four,
stage five.
So he didn't know he was sick and just decided,
fuck it.
I'm not going to pay taxes.
I'm just going to ride this out.
This was,
I mean,
he didn't pay taxes I think for around 15 years.
He didn't pay taxes.
Yeah,
he didn't exist.
He didn't have a driver's license.
He faked a driver's license.
He got a fake Id.
Not you should.
He's a great dad.
He was like,
you should do a one man show about your dad.
I know.
Well that's the story on our each show is I talk about my dad too.
Wow,
that's amazing.
He would take me to Atlantic city all the time and he taught me how to sort of
count cards in blackjack,
like he was in addition to being a bookie,
he was a Sicko gambler.
Like that was the,
you know,
his big vice.
Like he never did drugs.
He never drank,
but he would gamble like all his money.
That's incredible,
man.
Yeah.
My grandmother got arrested when I was a little kid.
She used to run numbers for the mob and they wanted her to turn state's evidence
and she wouldn't do it.
So they locked her in jail for six months.
So whenever we would go visit my grandma,
like she wouldn't be there and my grandfather were there.
Oh,
your grandma's visiting aunt Josie.
She was like,
have some things she was doing.
She's with aunt Marie this week.
She was like,
it was some story,
but meanwhile she was in some cell somewhere because she wouldn't rat on these
guys don't do like their version of the lottery.
It would be like running numbers.
Like there would be the numbers is how much people bet total.
Right.
Yeah.
I did a version of that when I was in high school.
There was um,
football cards that you could sell,
which was,
it's the craziest thing.
It's,
you basically have to pick out of,
um,
I think you list like 10 games that weekend and all the football games and you
have to pick five winners out of the 10,
which is like,
it feels easy.
Right?
But it's like so difficult out of these games to pick five winners and like you
charge like $5 a card and if like you know less than half the people when you
make money and it was,
I was making money doing this for like all of high school and then in college I
became like a real book.
You like I would actually get clients.
That's so crazy.
Yeah.
I would go to these frat parties and get all these frat kids to bet through me.
Whoa.
Do you have any issues with that?
Like guy's not paying or with like the school finding out?
Yeah you do.
You have like a few issues but then it's just they can't bet anymore and they
want a bet these people want to bat like there's never,
you never need to strong arm people because they just can't bet next week if
they don't pay and everyone wants it.
That I've never understood that.
When you,
when you do that,
do you have to have like a stash of cash that you can match up with?
Well,
I had a deal,
worked out with my dad's gambling office where they would pay all of my losses
and I would keep half my winnings.
Ah,
so no matter who lost,
they would pay them and I would just keep half the winning.
Now when you did that,
did you have to have like a really sick knowledge of sports?
Did you get into it?
Yeah.
How much time does it require?
A lot.
And you've got to,
you got to stay on top of the odds because they're constantly changing and if a
lot of people are betting on one side,
you got to move the,
the,
the points spread to,
to favor the other side so people bet the other side.
Wow.
Yeah,
it was nuts.
So you do like,
you could make up fun like prop bets.
Like they have weird stuff.
Like will the Broncos score as much as Shaquille O'neil on Sunday?
Oh,
weird.
Crazy.
But crazy bets.
Yeah.
Those were bets of people got accused of like shaving on that.
Like they got informed,
you know,
about certain things like,
no,
I'm not saying you should lose this game,
but if you do this,
it would behoove us,
oh,
that happens to get to a certain number.
Like you know,
Dude,
you're at 32.
Oh right,
okay,
cool,
cool.
And just throw some bricks.
I learned,
you know,
I apparently,
I didn't know this,
that like uh,
my dad would fix horse races.
That was his
big thing was you would just basically pay a Jackie to,
to hold a horseback.
I knew a jock.
You got arrested for that.
Yeah.
It all,
it's so common apparently.
Yeah.
There's a guy who used to run those chariots,
you know those chariots.
You ever see those cold like,
yeah.
Yeah.
And he literally stood up to try to get the horse of slowed down because he was
winning and they caught him standing up like you piece of shit.
He does a,
you,
you hold them back for several races.
They become a huge underdog and then you let them lose and they win.
That's like,
it's the classic way to,
to,
to do it.
Well,
this guy was trying to slow his horse down and they,
you know,
they barred him from being a jockey ever again.
And then he went and hired,
hired William Kunstler.
Some counselor kept talking about it.
He's a legend.
I got constantly my side,
I'm going to assume these cocksuckers and not going to make any money.
George the Greek,
he was this guy in the Greek,
he died of cancer too.
You know what Jimmy?
The Greek,
there's like a whole documentary about it.
Oh sure.
Yeah.
That's the guy that popularized gambles.
Butts were higher.
Yeah.
That's why you got a fire where,
yeah,
you were saying about slave owners breeding,
you know,
the largest blocks with the uh,
yeah,
yeah.
That was his whole thing.
But meanwhile,
you know,
he makes them like actual points.
Like they did do that.
Like they,
they did have slaves where they guaranteed took the largest males.
Yeah.
And tried to make them with the largest females to make stronger slaves.
I mean that has to have happened at some point in time.
You know,
and it's the athletics that you see like from,
from black African Americans is like they're the best athletes on earth and
where your white guy and your name is Jimmy the Greek,
you got to try to figure out why that is,
you know,
and you gotta be so sure about it even though it's not scientific for him it was
like,
yeah.
You know,
what they used to do is to take the,
the guys with the fucking biggest dicks and the best athletes,
they breed them with the biggest women and they make the biggest slaves,
like bought a big bottle home.
But they would say crazy shit back then on TV,
like Howard Cosell got in trouble for smoke smoke on the,
that little monkey run like that was like a statement that he had of a,
there was a football player who was like really fucking fast.
Well,
what becomes taboo changes all the time.
Right?
You ever,
have you ever go back recently and watched like Eddie Murphy raw or odd?
Yeah.
I was just like,
oh my God,
this is all gate.
This is all like homophobic,
weird,
weirdly angry towards gay people material.
Yeah.
And everybody went along with it.
Like there was a way back then.
All you just do say just fuck fucking faggot.
And everybody was,
yeah.
Oh,
in my lifetime,
faggot was fine.
It was fine to say like I,
I remember when I was a kid,
it was just like,
it's just a fun word.
And now it's like,
it's on the par of the n word.
Yeah.
You're not supposed to use it anymore.
It's too bad.
It was a great word while it lasted.
I miss it.
And even when it was not used in a gay sense,
you know the facts of pen.
Yeah.
It's a little faggot monkey over here to try and throw bananas at me.
Get back up you tree.
Yeah.
This is,
I feel like we're going to get a Jessebelle article about this podcast.
Why would not say anything that's run on right?
We're fine.
We're not,
we're not like,
we're not on the side of Jimmy the Greek or on the side of,
uh,
people that are calling up football player on Monday.
We'll just say in a weird,
but black people can run better.
I mean,
we could all look,
well,
I don't know why it's racist to say the best athletes.
I don't know why that's racist.
It's good.
They're better.
Like,
look at Lebron James,
look at Kobe Bryant,
look at John Jones,
look at it and there's a scroll.
John said it's sugar ray Leonard.
That's what they're,
you know,
in their lack of educational infrastructure,
that's what they're able to do.
Maybe that's what,
that's who their role models are.
There's also like bone density.
African Americans have a significantly more bone density than white people.
In fact,
African American women on par a lot of times have a similar bone density to
white European men.
It's weird.
Yeah.
There's like physical advantages to being a African America,
especially like there's people from certain parts of Africa that are just
unbelievably good at running to the point where all marathon runners and all
these like Olympic medalists and like certain distance running came from with
wipe out all Norway and they have huge people.
They're like,
Scandinavians are sure.
I was just in Sweden past weekend.
Yeah,
they're like all like a lot of biking.
Look,
God's huge looking dudes.
And again,
where's that square jaws?
Genetics.
Like those were vikings.
They literally were vikings.
Yeah.
I mean,
why were vikings bigger?
They got the spoils.
They got all the food.
They got the food and the the toughest and the strongest state alive.
They live in these harsh northern climates way before they had anything other
than burning wood to stay warm.
I mean that they survived like that for hundreds and hundreds of years and
there's just a strong genes of these vikings.
But it's okay to be a viking because then you are,
you know,
you were a conqueror,
you will like a winner.
But if you like,
say that someone has like really good genes because they were a slave,
it's like derogatory.
So that's where people take issue with it,
you know?
Oh,
I can see why people take issue with it.
Like if there was a bunch of people that were from north,
if you try to,
if you will,
like some shitty Greek type guy and you're on TV.
The thing about these guys from Sweden,
fucking Norway is the bigger,
because they used to kill everybody.
They were on horses,
they had big sword.
There were big guys from Norway,
all of the fucking ones that were bigger survive.
They would breed the big males with the big females and they would come with the
best athletes.
Yeah.
Nobody even from Norway would get mad at,
you know what I mean?
The bad thing is I grew up with guys like that.
Like all my dad's friends were like that.
My uncles were like that,
and he just would be just so casually racist at the dinner table,
you know?
I mean,
seriously,
you know,
like even now,
like my parents,
my mom,
my ground,
you
know,
they'll just be like,
I just don't understand why Mexicans have to be here.
You know?
Like they'll say things like that,
like just so reasonable.
Like just like,
I just don't understand.
Why do they have to be here?
There were people that grew up in a certain pattern and that certain pattern,
which is normal to distrust people of other ethnicities and races.
It's like that's the pattern.
It's so normal soldered into your brain and to break that pattern.
It was all the humor.
It was all the humor of my family growing up was racial.
Imagine if someone tried to put on like Archie bunker on a TV show today.
Oh yeah.
How long would that last?
How long would it last before he wouldn't even,
it would implode just by Twitter and Facebook comments.
Yeah.
It'd be a great podcast though.
The Archie Bunker podcasts,
you can't be racist like that anymore.
He just doesn't exist.
No,
it's the other way is,
you know,
you have to have every type of demographic in a show.
Yeah.
You got to cover everything.
You got to cover every single base from top to bottom.
Yeah.
I mean,
we live in a time where people just more aware of what was fucked up about the
past too.
We live in a time where people were more aware of what was really bad about,
you know,
or,
or what's going on.
Now.
People are really aware of that.
Like I don't think there could have been,
there could be another holocaust now people would know about it instantly.
I wonder,
I mean,
look at North Korea,
they could have something similar there and I wonder how much,
how many people would have to die before they would act before people,
they don't have oil there.
They don't have resources that we need.
Yeah.
Right.
But I mean like how far can it go?
I mean,
he is essentially the last of the great dictators.
Right?
How far do you think he'd go with his like human rights atrocities before we as
a,
you know,
United world said,
fuck this.
It's clear.
All he would have to do is,
is go past a border once.
Once he got,
he's like,
I need more land or I need more people or I need more resources,
then we're just like,
no way it happened.
It was the Korean War,
right?
Yeah.
Was that,
we're just fine.
He's,
if he's contained,
they're killing all these people that we don't care about,
you know?
Yeah.
It was that one of the,
it's one of the few times in history where there's like there's a North Korea
and South Korea and they live right next to each other and they fucking hate
each other and they look exactly the same.
Well it's in,
there were Pakistan it was like that too similar but they have different
religions.
Right.
Don't they?
It doesn't.
Indian Pakistan delete shit like Indians more Hindu,
Pakistani Muslim.
Yeah.
There is a,
there is a religious war there but they are so close.
There was this vice documentary about,
um,
I feel like vice docker decorators are just like fodder for hipsters to have
conversations.
They are guys,
doc man,
no where they show the border and there's just these troops just staring at each
other like Pakistan trips in India trips.
Just like looking at each other a few feet away,
just like don't do man.
And they all have
bombs,
both sides.
Oh they are?
They have nukes.
Yeah.
It's like us being at war with Mexico,
you know,
like going down to La Jolla and you look at tanks pointing in your yeah.
Mexico.
Yeah.
A big part of it.
That's,
that's uh,
that's one of the big issues with some people in la.
I said La was stolen from the Mexicans.
You know,
there was some radical UCLA professor that I ever had this video.
So he was putting out about this was stolen Latino land and like,
yeah,
this crazy speech that he was giving,
like stolen.
Like what generation are we talking about here,
man?
Like when,
when was this stolen?
I mean it was,
it was one.
Yeah,
in a war by the way.
It wasn't yours to begin with.
Like who's w w w what,
what about the native Americans?
Well,
you know what?
Mexico is native American plus Spanish.
That's what it is.
Spanish came down,
landed the anchors,
they bread,
everybody had sacks.
They,
you know,
I mean that is a lot of what Mexico is.
That's a lot of Mexican heritage has to do with people from Spain who came over
to Mexico.
I mean that is,
that's the real reality.
And you want it,
you go back before then,
like w w what was,
you know,
are we going to give everything to the Inuits?
So we're going to give everything to the people that came over from Asia and the
Bering Strait.
Like they're the original ones.
The native Americans are the original Mexicans,
original North Americans like this.
It wasn't all Mexico.
This is all people.
It's all people,
you know,
and we destroyed them.
The only like arc,
like though annihilated these people.
Yeah,
we wipe them off the face of the earth.
There's a lot of that.
The other argument is that we don't let them come over here.
Like,
you know,
there's a clear border,
there's like a lot of issues.
Like it's hard to just get over here.
Like you can't just like,
it doesn't matter who owns it.
It's,
everybody's not really,
you know,
of course you can't really come over here if you do.
They keep an eye on you.
They don't want you to stay.
Right.
Did you hear what he just busted a Russian spiring recently?
Like that's still a thing.
We still have Russian spies.
What'd you hear about the hot chick that they have?
That was a Russian spies.
There was a hot chick that was like chatting guys up and getting information.
Wow.
She's back.
She's like a superstar back in Russia.
We deported her.
Isn't that Russia is a villain again?
That's what I mean.
It's been mad at you always have been.
I think it's just not cool at all.
Is this really the only way that you could search things yet?
We have to see you search in front of those cameras now.
That's the only way to do it then Amy Adams.
Okay,
let's buy a couple more things cause it was awkward.
Yeah,
that's her.
That's the,
uh,
the Russian and she's in like the maximum diversion of Maxim in Russia.
Look,
she frictional flushed and hot is more interesting than anything else that you
do.
Oh yeah.
Was she an escort or what?
How did she,
well,
she was a spy and she worked for,
what is,
she would like
mate with guys,
breed with them,
get their sperm and their ideas and information.
She would,
um,
oh,
she sent marriage.
He looks like a bond,
like a bond spy.
She looks really looks like it.
She tweeted a marriage proposal,
but that was back in 2013 she might have since gone on to a thousand different
dicks.
Yeah,
that's the next article.
Yeah.
Who knows?
Who knows who?
She's Russian spy.
It goes to a thousand decks.
It's hilarious though that they hired a woman to go over and seduce men and get
information from them.
Smart.
It's cute.
Russians,
man.
They will never be okay with just being number two.
Number two.
Yeah.
They can't,
nobody wants to sell to all these guys do like Putin and all the guys who run
the government were part of,
you know,
the real USSR.
They were raised in that.
Yeah.
That's normal to them.
Well,
Putin is the most gangster of all the people today that's in control of a large
government.
Right?
Because he's so transparent.
Like when they arrest people and take away their businesses and throw them in
the Gulag and,
right.
It's awful.
It's like they're Reagan.
Yeah.
He's way worse than that.
Anybody like Putin,
the guy got elected out,
like he laughed,
like he did his term,
laughed,
put some puppet government in his place and then went back and started running
it again.
They're very alpha culture.
I grew up with a lot of Russians,
like it's really all about strongest,
most,
you know,
best jewelry,
best dressed.
It's like very alpha.
Like these guys are so alpha.
While they have to be probably survived that weather isn't there.
Probably some lightweight meet a lot of Phila jumpsuits if you're living in
Russia,
you know what I mean?
Like the genetics,
just the culture in the genes to survive that sort of an environment.
Unbelievably harsh climate.
You know?
So many didn't scant resources under the thumb of an oppressive government.
Yeah.
I just read a stat that I'm directly related to Stalin,
like directly related,
49 million people died.
Wow.
He killed 49 million people during his reign.
That's insane.
Yeah.
That's great.
I never would have thought it was that high.
Yeah.
49 million.
Wow.
Like unnatural causes.
That's so,
and he put them in camps like concentration camps and stuff.
Isn't it funny that he doesn't get brought up the same way or does or any of
these in that crazy horrible murders because he's too scary.
He has too much power.
I think that Olin or,
I mean,
uh,
I think meant fashion Russia in general.
You know,
we're talking about someone count 49 billion PT killed 49 million people.
Yeah.
That's so bizarre.
That does not brought up on a regular basis.
I couldn't believe it either.
I looked at,
I was like,
this can't be real.
Yeah.
He would,
you know,
he basically would just send people to these Siberian gulags because what do
they,
and they would just work to death and he would just kill them.
What's the number of people that Hitler supposedly killed?
My eight 8 million right now.
Weird.
Yeah.
It weird.
That's very strange that he's responding.
I mean,
it was so much more,
Hitler did that very quickly too and was going to keep going I think so it was
just,
he just,
just getting ramped up.
Yeah.
Hiller is,
is like a different category than any evil.
You know,
there's like evil and then there's a huge jump to Hitler.
No one even approaches that.
Well,
I think the really scary thing about Hitler for a lot of people,
it wasn't just that he was evil because there have been evil people throughout
history,
but that he was incredibly charismatic and we can watch it,
right?
We can actually see it on a film for like one of the first times.
Like if someone can go back and see video footage of Alexander the Great and go,
oh,
that's what was going on.
Or Napoleon,
oh,
that's what was going on.
We could see Stalin and we don't talk about that.
Yup.
Yeah,
yeah.
There's something about those speeches that Hitler gave though,
where he was out there in front of all the fucking hair was going crazy and he's
screaming and he's mapped up right now that we know like what he was doing.
He was messed up.
He was all messed up.
Harry was,
he was a great artist.
Painter.
Yeah.
Let's see.
George W.
Bush was a painter too.
Oh,
he's great.
Have you seen the,
it's like a Karma.
He paints,
paints stuff that like a nine year old would paint.
Yeah,
I think he paints like her dog and Turkey.
exactly.
Turkey.
Yeah.
He paints like a kid and like,
you know the look has a little blue underneath it as the background and then
that's it.
It's artwork is dog shit.
Hitler.
No,
she's just crying.
You got to pay attention.
You can't just sit there on your iPad and seriously,
you can't just interject in the middle.
This is twice you did that in a row or you didn't know were saying
no,
I know what you were saying the first time in the second time I was looking at
star and it says 40 to 60 million is what I was watching when you guys started
this second story,
you said a was how many million did you say?
49 million.
Yeah.
They were saying actually,
uh,
historians are saying 40 to 60 million.
So that's what I was looking at law and I thought you guys were talking.
No,
we were just talking about George Bush,
his artwork,
his dogs aren't Hitler killed 60 million.
No,
no.
40 to 60 right.
It's a shock when you're talking about people being murdered.
That's a huge range.
Fuck.
Maybe 20 more million.
Often the case with serial killers too,
like everybody's scared of like certain serial killers and then you hear about
some that no one even knows about and they killed her honored pills.
How does everybody not know everything about how many serious look is this
fucking shitty artworks as George Bush shitty art work?
Yeah.
He trusts puppies and shit.
And he wears.
He wears an apron.
You know,
I'm ready to paint with an apron on or do you imagine the fucking nightmares
that guy must have?
I don't think he knows.
I don't think.
I think that guy is so simple that he just has just like whatever.
Some people told me to do things and I did them might be right.
Yeah,
he might be right.
That guy sleeps just fine.
What about Dick Cheney?
How's he sleep?
He sleeps with a baby
in his mouth.
He sleeps chewing on a baby.
He painted and I know a painting is perfect.
That's hilarious.
George Bush made a painting of Jay Leno for j ladder.
He gives you a painting.
Wow.
Who would thing?
Who would have thought that guy was a war criminal?
You imagine all the time he spent making that painting.
Just imagine how creepy you would feel about George Bush just sitting there
thinking of nothing but you for hours while he's painting.
You look how proud he looks.
He's like,
I made this short.
You and Jay Leno's like it's haunted.
Oh,
that's great.
I feel it.
It's got the texture.
I'm a million dead Iraqis.
I found the weapons of mass destruction and it's this fucking painting.
It's terrible artwork,
man.
Weird that this guy is like one of the most hated figures in American politics
ever worldwide.
Like George w people connect him with the Iraq war,
the Afghanistan war with all,
he's going to go down as one of the worst ever.
If not though worst,
we're still too close to it.
Well,
the poor decisions that were made following nine 11 and how nine 11 happened,
you know,
and then all a crazy conspiracy people that think that he was in on it or they
were in on it and yeah.
And you know,
all those conspiracies when they're like,
it's an inside job.
It's never like Bush,
you know,
it's like some rogue CIA guy,
you know?
I feel like people think that like bushes.
They're just like,
okay,
we got to knock down these towers.
Do you remember?
I'm Vincent the Chin Gigante.
Oh yeah,
yeah.
Well,
he was like,
well,
immersed in the crime world because your dad,
he used to walk around like a crazy person with a bathrobe on and act like he
was nuts.
Yeah.
And that's how he got away with a lot of what he did.
Like you wouldn't talk to anybody in his house.
He would go walk and he would walk and talk to people and he would act like he
was nuts all the time.
Well,
I think it also came out later that he was nuts.
Schizophrenia.
Yeah.
Well I guess if you act like him that's long enough.
Eventually.
Maybe the like nature,
it's like you don't hold your eyes like that will stay that way.
You know?
It's maybe it's one of those things.
Yeah.
You like hide in plain sight kind of thing.
Well,
maybe Bush is like a really smart guy and everybody's shut.
Shut the door is everybody gone.
Listen man,
I knew what the fuck was going on.
How do you think,
and nobody,
nobody's angry at me.
Notice that everybody hates Dick Cheney.
I believe that the powers like the real powers,
like,
you know,
not like Illuminati type stuff,
but like,
you know the guys like the robes and the Karl Rove's and the,
the people who actually get presidents elected,
they don't want to choose people that have a lot of independent opinions.
They want to choose people that are just gonna be like,
okay,
sure,
sure.
Well that's John F.
Kennedy who want power so bad that they'll just be willing to do anything for
it,
you know,
and John F.
Kennedy,
that was like the big knock on him was that he wouldn't play ball is that,
you know,
he had this idea in his head how he was going to do things and they shot it out
of them I think.
And people too,
you know,
there was like,
why don't they just do what they said they were going to do during the election.
And I found out once that,
you know,
there's a full day when you are elected where they take you to the CIA,
if you're elected president,
they take you there and they tell you all the secrets.
Like they tell you all the secrets that people don't know,
like,
uh,
for a full day,
they're just like,
okay,
here's,
here's all the shit that the American public does not know.
And then I feel like you're like,
oh,
well I can't do any of that stuff.
I said like,
there's like aliens pointing something at us,
you know,
who knows what,
you know?
Well,
there's for sure some shit that we're doing like covertly,
but a lot of people were going to close Guantanamo Bay.
Actually.
I'm,
no,
you're not.
And here's why.
And you're like,
Oh yeah,
I'm not.
Yeah,
of course.
Yeah.
There's so much stuff.
Fuck.
And there's so many financial interests I've got to pee.
Is that,
yeah.
Cool.
Go ahead and I do that.
Yeah.
We got to wrap this thing up sooner.
Unfortunately.
I gotta wake up out of here.
All right.
We'll just wrap it up,
man.
You are,
I'm episode is going to be when your episode on this,
this is not happening on the 12th,
the 12th,
February,
2012 and this is not happening is on hold 30 am on comedy central.
And what nights?
Uh,
what's the 12th Thursday night?
Thursday,
Thursday nights at 1230 and it's our pow Ari Shaffir show and a Barry Rothbart.
You could follow him on Twitter.
Dude.
We got to do another one.
Let's do a longer one next time.
I have more time and you don't want to fucking awesome.
I love talking to,
you're funny dude.
Very interesting story to tell.
Life stories.
Amazing,
Huh?
Yeah,
we get into it.
So follow him on Twitter,
Twitter,
back.
Barry Rothbart and um,
uh,
watch his show on February 12th,
12th.
Yes.
On comedy central.
1230 on Thursday night.
This is not happening.
All right,
friends.
We'll see you next week.
Much love.
Turn it on.
It.